واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في حصاد هذه
الليله وفي ابرز
مواضيعه بعد نحو 24 ساعه من الغموض تاكد
مقتل قائد فاجنر بوتين يعزي عائله يفجيني
بريغوجين ويشيد بقائد فاجنر ويقول انه
ارتكب اخطاء ويكشف انه اجتمع بمسؤولين في
موسكو قبل حادث تحطم
طائراته بعد زيلنسكي قائد القوات
الامريكيه المشتركه يقول ان واشنطن لا
علاقه لها باستهداف طائره بريغوجين تقارير
استخباريه امريكيه تتحدث عن احتمال
تفجيرها من الداخل والبنتاجون ينفي فرضيه
قصفها بصاروخ ويقول ان مجموعه فاغنر تمثل
تهديدا حقيقيا وان نشاطها في افريقيا
سيراقب لاول مره منذ ضمم روسيا لشبه جزيره
القرم القوات الاوكرانيه تعلن تنفيذ عمليه
انزال في شبه الجزيره وتقول انها قتلت 30
جنديا روسيا وسائل اعلام روسيه تنقل عن
مخابرات موسكو ان عمليه الانزال افشلت
بقتل جميع الجنود
المشاركين حراك دولي واقليمي يتسارع بشان
ازمه انقلاب نيجر مستشارو الامن القومي في
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا والمانيا
وايطاليا وفرنسا يشددون على العمل لاعاده
النظام الدستوري مسؤول جزائري يجري
محادثات في نيامي ووفد علماء نيجيريا
للمره الثالثه في النيجر ويقول انه يسعى
للحصول على
[موسيقى]
التزامات اذا قدم الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين التعازي لعائله رئيس شركه فاغنر
يفجيني بريجن وقال بوتين خلال لقاء مع
رئيس دونيتسك الموالي لروسيا دينس بوشيلين
انه عرف بريغوجين منذ تسعينيات القرن
الماضي كرجل اعمال
موهوب فيما يتعلق بهذه الماساه الجويه اود
اولا ان اقدم خالص التعازي لاسر الضحايا
انها ماساه اذا كان ضمن الركاب موظفو شركه
فاغنر والبيانات الاوليه تشير الى وجودهم
فاود الاشاره الى ان هؤلاء الاشخاص قدموا
مساهمه كبيره في قضيتنا المشتركه المتمثله
في محاربه نظام النازيين الجدد في
اوكرانيا نحن ندرك ذلك ولن ننساه عرفت
بريغوجين منذ فتره طويله منذ بدايات
تسعينيات القرن الماضي لقد كان مصير الرجل
معقدا كانت له اخطاء كثيره في حياته وحقق
نتائج مهمه له للامور المشتركه كما في
الاشهر الاخيره كان شخصا موهوبا ورجل
اعمال موهوبا وليس في روسيا فحسب لقد حقق
نتائج في افريقيا حيث كان يعمل في مجال
النفط والغاز والمعادن والاحجار النفيسه
اخر المعلومات تشير الى انه وصل امس فقط
من افريقيا والتقى هنا ببعض الشخصيات
الرسميه رئيس لجنه التحقيقي ابلغني اليوم
بانهم بداوا بالفعل تحقيقا اوليا في هذا
الحادث وسينفذ الكامل دعونا نرى ما سيقوله
المحققون في المستقبل القريب الان تجرى
الفحوصات الفنيه والوراثيه وهذا سيستغرق
بعض
الوقت ينضم الينا الان من محيط موقع تحطم
الطائره في بلده كوجين كينو شمال غرب
موسكو مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي ومعنا من
امام مقر شركه فاغنر في سان بترسبورغ
مراسله الجزيره رانيا اليدي مرحبا بكما
سنبدا معك امين غامي واخر مستجدات
التحقيق نعم مسي عمليات التحقيق ما زالت
متواصله في مكان تحطم هذه الطائره طبعا
هذا المكان مطوق بشكل كامل ويمنع على
الجميع الوصول الى تلك المنطقه نقف
في منطقه او نقطه تبعد بنحو كيلومتر فقط
عن مكان تحط هذه الطائره وكانت معظم لجان
التحقيق اضافه الى مختلف اجهزه الامن
الروسيه قد انسحبت تباعا من موقع تحطم
الطائره بعد ان كانت
قد نقلت سيارتين لنقل الاموات على ما يبدو
جثث للضحايا
فجر اليوم بعد ذلك تم نقل بعض المتعلقات
و الاشياء التي تم العثور عليها في موقع
تحطم هذه الطائره والتي قد تساعد في سير
هذه التحقيقات وبعد ذلك طبعا وصلت قوى
الامن تطويق هذه المنطقه و طبعا تواصل
عمليات التحقيق والبحث عن ما قد يفيد في
هذه العمليه خاصه وان هناك اسئله ما زالت
معلقه حتى الان السي خاصه تلك المتعلقه
بمصير الصندوقين الاسودين حتى الان لم
تصدر اي تصريحات تؤكد او
تنفي عثور المحققين على هذين الصندوقين
نعلم جيدا ان عمليه فحص محتوى الصندوق
الاسود او الصندوقين الاسودين تتطلب وقتا
طويلا انطلاقا من تفريغ محتويات
والتسجيلات طبعا من داخل غرفه ال التحكم
والقياده مرورا بمسار خريطه مسار هذه
الرحله منذ اقلاعها من مطار شيريميتيفو في
موسكو حتى لحظه تحطمها في هذه المنطقه
طبعا في المواقف الرئيس الروسي طبعا كان
قد حسم الجدل على الاقل المتعلق بمصير
يفجيني بريغوجين خاصه بعد تلك الاسئله
التي بقيت لنحو 24 ساعه معلقه والتي كانت
تتمحور بالدرجه الاولى حول مصير يفجيني
بريغوجين ما اذا كان قد قتل بالفعل ام لا
عندما قدم طبعا بوتين التعازي لعائله
افجين بروكوجنين
كانوا معه اعلمت هذه الطائره وبعد ذلك
طبعا صدر تصريح مقتضب على لسان وزير
الخارجيه سيرجي لافروف الذي سئل ع ما يتم
تداوله عبر بعض وسائل الاعلام الاجنبيه
قال بان التحقيقات ما زالت جاريه ودعى الى
التركيز فقط على المص صادر الرسميه الى
حين انتهاء هذه التحقيقات
وعدم الانتباه والاقتضاء من طبعا ما يتم
تناقله عبر وسائل الاعلام الغربيه منها
خاصه كل ذلك طبعا ياتي
بعد وسط صمت لنقل من قبل لجنه التحقيق
الروسيه الفيدراليه المكلفه بسير هذه
التحقيقات عن اسئله ما زالت حتى الان
معلقه صلا حول الصندوقين الاسودين ما يمكن
تاكيده حتى الان هو ان حطام هذه الطائره
حتى الان لم يتم اخراجه من تلك المنطقه
التي تحطمت فيها لربما مازالت عمليات
البحث جاريه عن بعض اجزاء هذه الطائره مع
العلم ان ديل هذه الطائره يعني سقط في
منطقه تبعد باكثر من كيلومترين عن مكان
سقوط جسم الطائره وهذا ربما يفتح الباب
امام تساؤلات كثيره وامام ايضا
فرضيات كثيره متعلقه بالدرجه الاولى
باسباب تحطم هذه الطائره الاسباب المباشره
بطبيعه الحال والتي قد تجيب عنها نتائج
التحقيقات خلال ربما الايام القليله
المقبله رانيا دريدي في سان بترسبورغ من
امام مقر شركه فاغنر نشاهد من خلفك عدد من
المواطنين متجمعين هناك وشموع وورود عند
الشركه قد بين اكثر من المشهد ومن مشهد
ردود الفعل في روسيا عموما بعد الاعلان عن
مقتل بريغوجين
نعم بالفعل السي نحن نتواجد حاليا امام
مركز شركه فاجنر العسكريه الخاصه وبالفعل
يعني يمكن القول ان هناك توافد مستمر
للمواطنين الروس الى هذا المكان حيث تم
يعني تشييد ان صح التعبير نصب تذكاري مؤ
لف من الورود والشموع وقد تكون الصوره
اوضح الس لو يعني نظرنا على كثب هناك
العديد من اعلام اعلام التي تمثل شركه
فاغنر العسكريه الخاصه هناك العديد من
الورود والشموع فعليا العشرات من
المواطنين الروس اود الاشاره الى اننا
نتجه نحو منتصف الليل السي ولكن مع ذلك
وعلى الرغم من انه ليس يوم عطله ولكن
المواطنون يتوافدون هناك من ياتي يضع
ويغادر مواطنون اخرون ياتون وبالفعل مثل
هذا يعني مثل هذه الخطوه قد تكون اشاره
الى دعم افراد الشعب الروسي المواطنين عدد
كبير منهم لهذه الشركه ولما تقوم به على
ساحات المعارك لا سما فيما يتعلق بما
يسميه الروس الانجازات التي تم تحقيقها من
قبل هذه الشركه الخاصه لا سما فيما يتعلق
بالسيطره على باخم نحن نع نعلم ان مقاتلو
شركه فاغنر كان يعني لعبوا الدور الاهم ب
للسيطره على هذه المدينه اذا يعني يعني
ايضا هنا لابد من الاشاره الى انه على
الرغم من مرور نحو شهرين السي على التمرد
المسلح يعني ولكن يعني اود الاشاره الى
انه على الرغم من هذه الخطوه التي يعني
وصفها الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
بالخيانه ولكن مع ذ ولن مع
ذلك ولكن مع
ذلك فان يعني ابناء الشعب الروسي لم
يكونوا
يعني يعني ضد هذه الخطوه كانت هناك جموع
كبيره من المواطنين الروس
الذين
الذين اعتقد ان
هناك مضيقه لزميله رانيا الموجوده في
سانس حتى تترتب الاوضاع رانيا سنعود اليك
اعود الى امين درغامي المتواجد في كوجين
كينو امين كنا نتحدث بشان التحقيقات ولجنه
التحقيق الفيدراليه التي تلتزم الصمت حتى
الان الرئيس الروسي قال انه سيجري التحقيق
حتى النهايه لمعرفه ما حدث متى يفترض او
يتوقع ان تظهر اي نتيجه
معينه
يبدو ان هذا الامر يتوقف السي
على جزئين اساسيين في التحقيقات الجزء
التقني والجزء الطبي الجزء التقني طبعا
سيتركز على فحص كل ما تم العثور عليه في
مكان تحطم هذه الطائره امس وفور وصولنا
عند الساعه الواحده ليلا الى هذه المنطقه
كانت هناك سيارات تابعه للجنه التحقيق
تغادر هذه المنطقه وتحمل صناديق يعتقد
انها بها بعض المتعلقات التي تم العثور
عليها في مكان تحطم هذه الطائره اضافه الى
فحص جسم الطائره اي الحطام لتحديد اسباب
تحطم هذه الطائره وبطبيعه الحال فحص محتوى
الصندوقين الاسودين بعد تاكيد مساله
العثور عليهما من عدمه وهو ما لم يصدر حتى
الان عن لجنه التحقيق وال المعطى الثاني
يتمثل في البحث
الجنائي واجراء الخبره الطبيه على الجثث
التي تم العثور عليها اضافه الى فحص الحمض
النووي لبعض الاشلاء خاصه وان هناك كان
فيديو امس قد انتشر السي يظهر بان بعض
الجثث تعرضت لاضرار كبيره لربما بعد
ارتطام هذه الطائره بالارض وبالتالي من
اجل تحديد هويات كل الجثث والتحقق
منه ستكون هناك طبعا بعض الفحوص على الحمض
النووي وبالتالي هذا الموضوع قد يتطلب اذا
لم نقل اسابيع لربما بضعه
ايام السلطات في روسيا تبقي مساله الكشف
عن نتائج هذه التحقيقات في اطار عمل
اللجان التي تقوم بهذه التحقيقات وهي
مكونه من عدد من الاجهزه بالاضافه الى
لجنه التحقيق
الفيدراليه سلطات مقاطعه ت فير
حيث يعني حيث نتواجد الان اضافه الى وزاره
الداخليه وزاره الطوارئ
وايضا الحرس الوطني الروسي ويعتقد ان هناك
خبراء ايضا من الجيش
الروسي يشاركون ب شكل من الاشكال في اتمام
هذه التحقيقات الكشف عن النتائج لربما
سيوضح الصوره حول ما جرى خاصه وان هناك
فرضيات طرحت وهذه الفرضيات في الحقيقه
السي هي مبنيه على بعض المعطيات
المتوفره والتي تزامنت مع سقوط هذه
الطائره توقيت سقوطها متعلقه من جهه ببعض
تصريحات وشهادات السكان هذه البلده حيث
نتواجد حينما قالوا بانهم سمعوا دوي
انفجارين سبقا بثواني
قليله هبوط هذه الطائره وارتطام بالارض
وايضا هناك من شاهد دخان كان يتصاعد من
الطائره قبل ان تهبط بشكل عمودي وترتطم
بالارض ومعطى اخر بان الطائره قبل ان تهبط
ان تهوي وترتطم بالارض كانت قد فقدت
جناحها الايسر وهذا يفتح الباب امام
تساؤلات عن ما جرى قبل سقوط هذه الطائره
هل تعرضت لتخريب داخلي ادى الى انفجارها
في السماء قبل ان تتحطم
وتسقط ام انها ارتطمت بجسم معين صاروخ او
طائره مسيره او ما شابه ذلك كل هذه
الفرضيات محتمله
وطبعا مساله الكشف عن نتائج التحقيقات هي
الوحيده الكفيله بان تحدد ما جرى بالتح
تديد وهذا طبعا مناط بالدرجه الاولى بلجنه
التحقيق التي ذكرت وا ايضا بسير عمليات
التحقيق التي يبدو انها لن تكون سهله باي
شكل من الاشكال خاصه وان الحديث عن تطاير
شضايا هذه الطائره على مساحه واسعه الحديث
عن نحو كيلومترين او كيلومترين ونصف وايضا
للاضرار التي لحقت
بجثث القتلى العشره من ركاب هذه الطائره
وهم يفجيني برجوج اضافه الى سبعه
من من موظفي شركه فاجنر اضافه الى ثلاثه
اشخاص من طاقم الطائره نعم اشكرك امين
درغامي من محيط موقع تحطم الطائره في بلده
كوجك وشمال غربي موسكو كنت معنا من هناك
اذا والشكر موصول لزميله رانيا دريدي التي
كانت معنا من امام مقر شركه فاجنر في سان
بيترسبورج منذ الاعلان عن سقوط طائره
يملكها يفجيني بريغوجين تقطر مواطنون روس
على مقر فاغنر في مدينه سان بترسبورغ
لالقاء الورود رغم غياب اي اعلان رسمي في
الساعات الاولى التي تلت سقوط الطائره كيف
بدا المشهد في المدينه منذ ليل
الاربعاء يبكون يفك بريغوجين وقاده من
فاجنر في طقوس قد يصح وصفها بجنازه غير
رسميه في مدينته سان بيترسبورغ ويؤدون
التحيه لرجل يعتبره كثيرون في روسيا بطلا
قوميا رغم انه شخصيه مختلف عليها كل شيء
بدا مساء الاربعاء ات طائره مدنيه في شمال
موسكو فتغيرت ديناميكيات كثيره ليس في
روسيا فقط فترددت تسمع وراء الحدود
بيكوجين لم يكن مجرد شخصيه عسكريه عابره
ينسب لنفسه وقواته الفضل في حسم واحده من
اطول معارك الحرب في اوكرانيا باخم وهو ما
اكده الرئيس الروسي في تعزيه عائله الرجل
ثم دخلت فاجنر بمدرعات الاراضي الروسيه
وتوجهت نحو موسكو فاختلف في تصنيف افجين
برجوج بين من يراه بطلا قوميا ومن يصفه
بخائن العهد مع الدوله
الروسيه جدل لن يحسن لكن الصور الاتيه من
المدينه التي احتضنت مقر فاجنر يمكن ان
تقول انه بالنسبه لهؤلاء لا جدل بشان من
يكون يفك
برجن حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من موسكو
فاسيلي فاتي جارف الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي ومعنا من سان بترسبورغ
ديمتري سولون كوف المحلل السياسي
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بكما سنبدا معك سيد
دميتري سولون كوف كيف وجدت الدلالات من
وراء كيفيه الاعلان عن مقتل زعيم فاغنر
التعزيه التي وجهها الرئيس بوتين حديثه عن
انه رجل موهوب لكنه ارتكب
اخطاء
ان هذه نظره موضوعيه اي وفاه هي ماساه
ووفاه فريق الطيران على متن الطائره وهذه
الكارثه و تعزيه رئيس الدوله هذا شيء
طبيعي لهذه الظروف الكلمات التي قالها عن
برجن تؤكد دور
في تاريخ روسيا الحديث الشخص الذي قام
بالكثير من وجهه
نظر انشاء شركات استثمار والعمل مع روسيا
على اهم الاهداف الصعبه في الخارج الروسي
وفي اطار العمليه العسكريه الخاصه وكشخص
كان يعمل على مسائل معقده وربما قام
بالكثير بالاخطاء بعضها كان خطيرا
ومحوري مثل التمرد في هذا في العام السابق
و هذا كله اثر على حياته في الشهرين
الاخرين وهذا
تقدي تقيييم
لدوره وتاكيد على انه كان يقوم بامور صعبه
ومعقده وهذا يؤدي الى اخطاء سيد فاتي هل
من رسائل معينه يراد ارسالها من وراء
الطريقه التي اعلن بها عن مقتلي بريغوجين
من جانب الرئيس الروسي وحديث ال الرئيس
الروسي
عنه انا هنا لا ارى اي
رسائل مظلله وانا ص متفق مع الاخ دميتري
والزميل قال ما كان يريده ان شخصيه
بريغوجين كانت شخصيه متضاربه وقام بدور
مهم بل عظيم لروسيا وانا متاكد ان السيد
فلاديمير بوتين اكد ايضا ان بريغوجين
وقيادات واغنر وكل القوات في واغنر قاموا
بالكثير وقدموا الكثير لاجل النصر على
الفاشيه في اوكرانيا وهذا دور عظيم ولن
ننسى هذا ابدا وهذا ما اكده السيد
فلاديمير بوتين لذلك بالطبع اي كارثه واي
حاله وفاه هي ماساه بحد ذاتها اما وفاه
هؤلاء الاشخاص الموهوبين ليس يفجيني
بريغوجين فقط بل اتكن
والاخرين اريد ان اقول ان
بريغوجين
كشخص عسكري وكل من في فاجنر هم عسكريين هم
ابطال روسيين كرموا باعلى الاوسمه الروسيه
ولكن للاسف
الوفاه
هي تاخذ الافضل والان من الصعب ان نختلف
الان نحن اسين على وفاتهم سيد فاسيلي هناك
عنصر مهم في كل ما حدث هو التمرد الذي
قاده بريغوجين قبل شهرين في روسيا ووصف
الرئيس الروسي له في حينها بان بان ما جرى
خيانه اولا عندما قام الرئيس الروسي السيد
بوتين ونحن كنا معكم هنا في هذا الاستوديو
وقلنا
انه لم يسمي اسماء وعائلات
محدده كانت اعلانات حذره كما وان الرئيس
وعد وبشكل
شخصي قبل حتى المفاوضات اثناء مفاوضاته مع
لو كوشكا ان المسؤوليه على هذا
التمرد لن تكون ولن يحاسب احد ثم ق السيد
بوتين بلقاء السيد بريغوجين
وقيادات القيادات العسكريه بل مع مختلف
قيادات مجموعه واجنر وتحدثوا وناقشوا كل
شيء وبشكل واضح انهم وضعوا جميع النقط على
الحروف وانتهت هذه القضيه التي انتهت
بهدوء وكان من الممكن ان تنتهي بشكل اسوا
بكثير كل النقاط وضعت وكنت وانا متاكد
كغلي
الم ان وفاه السي ليست مرتبطه بالاحداث
السابقه نعم اخط الرل وكن وضحت فكرتك سيد
سيلي سيد دمتري سونيكو اذا هذه الوفاه
ليست مرتبطه بما حدث في السابق ولكن كيف
ستؤثر من وجهه نظرك على مجموعه
فاجنر ان مجموعه واجنر سوف تحافظ يحافظ
عليها وسوف تبقى قائمه على مهامها التي
سوف توضع من قبل الاداره الروسيه ولكنها
قد يعاد
تشكيلها سوف يظهر قائد جديد ولا نعلم من
سيكون هذا الشخص لاننا نعلم ان في حاله
وفاه اي قياده تظهر قياده جديده ولكن سوف
يكون هناك اعاده تشكيل وسوف تشكل المهام
الجديده التي سوف تعمل عليها تشكيله فنر
واعتقد ان اهم هذه المهام هي قضيه الوجود
في افريقيا
وحمايه المنشات الخارجيه وايضا التواجد في
بيلاروسيا وحمايه حدود بيلاروسيا ان فاجنر
كمجموعات اثبتت فعاليتها
وكال واعتقد انه ليس هناك اي مصلحه من
تفكيكها او حلها
قد تطور ولكن لن تحل كيف ستطور سيد فاسيلي
فاتي جاروف مجموعه فاجنر وكيف سيؤثر غياب
زعيمها
ومؤسسها على مجمل
عملها انا اعتقد ان اعاده تشكيل قوات
واغنر ستكون عميقه نعم انها تشكيلات فعاله
والرئيس اعترف بهذا ولكن بالنسبه للقيادات
والاداره من حسن الحظ ان ليست كل القيادات
قد قتلت في هذا الحادث لقد ذكر
الرئيس احد القيادات التي
تعتبر شخصيه قياديه وعد عن ذلك اكد الرئيس
انه
من جانب قانوني الشركات العسكريه الخاصه
ومنها فاغنر هي امور ليست موجوده بشكل
قانوني في روسيا
واعتقد ان الان قد يكون هناك اتخاذ قرارات
قانونيه تحدد وجود هذه الشركات العسكريه
ووجودها في روسيا و
واخضاعها للقياده العسكريه العليا على
راسها السيد بوتين شكرا لكما من موسكو
فاسيلي فاتي جاروف الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي ومن سان بترسبورغ دمتري
سولون كوف المحلل السياسي
والاستراتيجي احتمالات عديده يممكن ان
يكون احدها سببا مباشرا لتحطم الطائره
ويبقى ظهور الحقيقه رهنا بما تقرر السلطات
الروسيه اعلانه بعد انتهاء التحقيقات
لكننا في التقرير التالي نستعرض اهم
سيناريوهات سقوط
الطائره هذا السقوط الذي رصدته عدسات
لطائره شركه فاجنر قد يعزز احتمالات دون
اخرى بشان السبب الحقيقي لكنه لا يجيب
بشكل حاسم عما ادى تحديدا لاسقاطها وعليها
ملك الشركه يفجيني بريغوجين يرى عسكريون
ان ثمه احتمالا من ثلاثه اما الخلل الفني
او الاستهداف من الداخل بقنبله مزروعه
سلفا او من الخارج بصاروخ قد تستبعد فرضيه
الخلل الفني الذي ليس من شانه قطع الاتصال
مع قمره القياده ولا تغييب الطائره عن
شاشات الرادار بشكل فوري وهو ما وقع فعليا
بعد 26 دقيقه من الاقلاع كما تستبعد فرضيه
الخلل الفني لاستقرار معدل ارتفاع الطائره
وفق بيانات موقع فلايت رادار بشان احتمال
الاستهداف الخارجي فارتفاع الطائره لنحو 3
الف قدم يرجح استخدام صواريخ متوسطه او
بعيده المدى فهل استخدمت في تلك المناطق
المدنيه كما ان هذه الصواريخ لو اصابت جسم
الطائره فستفل ولن تسقط متماسكه كما ورد
في الصور لكن ماذا لو اصاب الصاروخ جناح
الطائره ففصل لتسقط بجناح واحد كما ذكر
شهود عيان احتمال قائم ينتظر التحقيقات
ويوضع في سياقه ايضا ما اورده خبراء حسب
معاينات اوليه حول ثقوب في جسم الطائره
ترجح اصابتها بصاروخ امات مال التفجير
الداخلي بقنبله فيبقى قائما وينتظر
تاكيدات فنيه حول موقع زرع القنبله ووزنها
وطريقه توجيهها وهل احدثت فجوه في جسم
الطائره اخلت بتوازنها لتسقط سريعا ام
فصرت الجزء الخلفي كما اورد تقرير لصحيفه
كوميرسانت الروسيه نقل عن خبراء في مجال
تحقيقات الكوارث الجويه اجابات تلك
الاسئله ما زالت حبيسه صندوقي الطائره
الاسودين الذين تتوقف سرعه كشف في ما
فيهما على قرار جهات التحقيق وعملها على
الارض ينضم الينا في الاستديو الدكتور عمر
عاشور استاذ الدراسات الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه مرحبا بك دكتور عمر يعني
بعد مرور 24 اكثر من 24 ساعه وبظل
المعطيات المتوافره هل يمكن ترجيح سيناريو
معين لما حدث وادى الى سقوط هذه الطائره
ويصعب تاكيد ولكن ترجيح يمكن ترجيح س
الانفجار الداخلي الذي حدث بع البعض بدا
ينظر حوله ويعطي بعض الدلائل لكن المشكله
الرئيسيه ان حتى في حاله التحقيق الرسمي
التي سيحقق هي جهات رسميه ربما راسها
مشتبه فيه في ان يكون هو من نفذ هذه
العمليه لو لو ثبت انها عمليه السيناريو
الاقل ترجيحا هو سيناريو الحادثه لانه هذه
طائره
حديثه الى حد ما مؤمنه يملكها يفجيني
بريجو المعروف انه مستهدف تسقط بهذه
الطريقه فسين يو الحادث ربما هو الاقل
ترجيحا او الاكثر ترجيحا من وجهه نظري
الموضوع المتعلق بزرع عبوه ما الذي يدفعنا
الى ان نعتقد ان السيناريو الاكثر ترجيحا
هو العبوه من
الداخل السقو هو حدث بعض الشروط تكلموا عن
سماع طلقتين او صاروخين قبل ذلك لكن في في
تقديري اصابه بمنظومه ربما اس 300 او اس
400 او او شيء اخر 29000 قدم ارتفاع عالي
يعني تحتاج منظومه بوك ربما ف
فبالتالي البايلود الموجو و كم المتفجرات
الموجود في هذه الصواريخ على طائره مدنيه
صغيره هذه ليست طائره عسكريه اظن انه كان
سيدمر بشكل اكبر بكثير مما رايناه لا ان
تسقط تقريبا سليمه بجناح مفقود ام فربما
السيناريو الاوضح او ربما السيناريو
ارجح ان تكون هناك
عبوه عبوه ربما اعود لما قاله مراسلنا من
عين المكان يتحدث عن ان السكان في المنطقه
يتحدثون عن انهم سمعوا ذوي انفجارين انه
كان الدخان يتصاعد من الطائره لدى سقوطها
وانها فقدت جناحها الايسر ما دلالات كل
ذلك يصعب كذلك يعني هذه كلها دلائل ربما
ترجح سيناريو على اخر لكن انها لا تؤكد
شيء
ف ربما يعني الاقرب لما هو حدث هو مازال
في في اعتقادي سيناريو العبوه نظرا لحجم
التدمير لكن ربما تكون هناك مفاجات اخرى
ستظهر المشكله الرئيسيه هي ان التحقيق لن
يكون تحقيق شفاف وواضح وهذا يعني الشواهد
كلها سواه السياسيه في في هذا
الموضوع ربما تجعلنا نجد انه لن يكون
تحقيق شفاف وواضح فربما لن نعلم ك لما كيف
سقطت هذه الطائره
و طيب ما الذي يمكن ان يقوم به الجانب
الروسي حتى يؤكد شفافيه التحقيق يعني الان
الكل بانتظار ما س يفصح عنه في الصندوق
الاسود هل هذا كافن ال الاعلان عن ما ورد
او ما وصل اليه او ما كشف عنه الصندوق
الاسود هل هو كاف ربما للتاكيد على شفافيه
التحقيق هو كافي لو راه محايد او مراقبون
محايدون او ربما محققون دوليون لكن لا اظن
ان هذا يسمع هذا يعني كان صراع داخلي
عسكري ما بين قائد لقوه غير نظاميه ربما
اكبر قوه غير نظاميه عرفتها روسيا بعد ما
بعد الاتحاد السوفيتي ورئيسها المباشر
يعني فاظن ان مستوى الصراع هنا عالي
للغايه على
ان يعني يدفع بتحقيق شفاف
دولي بشكل اكثر تفصيلا ويكون ا اكثر عداله
ف طيب ماذا عن المعلومات الوارده من الدول
الغربيه ال المعلومات الاستخباريه يعني
حتى البنتاغون الان يتحدث عن انه لا يمكن
ترجيح فرضيه على اخرى باعتقادك ماذا وراء
مثل هكذا موقف هو موقف مبدئي حتى الان هم
قالوا انهم يرجحوا فرضيه العبه كذلك ولكن
هذا موقف مبدئي لانه ايضا لن يتمكنوا ربما
يعني يستطيع ان يصلوا
لبعض الصور الاقمار الصناعيه شيء شيء يعني
اختراق ما في في المؤسسه الامنيه ربما يصل
الى شيء من هذا القبيل لكن يعني مره اخرى
تحقيق سيكون صعب للغايه في في الوصول
الى
يعني لماذا سقطت هذه الطائره بهذه الطريقه
طيب حتى ذلك الوقت اشكرك عمر عاشور استاذ
الدراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه ضيفنا هنا
في استديو الحصاد شكرا
لك بعد صمت طال كثيرا تاركا العالم في
فوضه تخمينات حول مصير يفجيني بريغوجين
مالك مجموعه فاغنر خرج الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين ليعلن مقتل بريغوجين في حادث تحطم
طائراته يتقدم بوتين بالتعزيه لاسره
بريغوجين الذي قال انه يعرفه منذ
التسعينيات رجل اعمال ناجحا وانه اسدى بعض
الخدمات لروسيا يقول بوتين ذلك ربما رعايه
لذكريات وربما دفعا لتهم تنال تنهال عليه
بانه هو من يقف وراء مقتل بريغوجين الذي
تجرا على تحديه واعلن تمرده عليه اختفاء
بريغوجين سيطرح اسئله عديده حول مصير قوات
فاغنر التي تبيع القتل مقابل المال وتصنع
لروسيا بايديها القدره ما لا تستطيع روسيا
صنعه بيد نظيفه في طلب النفوذ في العالم
لا سما في افريقيا تقرير فوزي
بشرى
مشهد للقوه للسلطه في تمام تجلياتها لا
يحتمل خدشا بمعارض كتومه او فصيحه لا
يحتمل منازعه عليها او تشكيكا فيها لكن
رجلا تجرا في لحظه سكره بقوته ونفوذه
وبغير قليل من الاجراء على الكرملين ان
يحدث نفسه بختش هذه الصوره صوره بوتين
وصوره الجيش الروسي الذي يخوض ضرو ضد
اوكرانيا لم يكن ذلك الرجل احدا غير افجين
بريجين انه السجين السابق الذي امضى في
السجن تسع سنوات من اصل عقوبه بلغت ا عش
سنه بسبب فساده واحتيال
وسرقاته يبلغ بريغوجين نهايه طموحه في
اعمال المطاعم وصناعه الطعام ويتحول الى
متعهد لعدد من المناسبات الرسميه في
الكرملين حتى لق به لقب طباخ الرئيس يرد
بريغوجين اليط اللسان يمكن ان اسمى بدقه
اكثر جزار الرئيس ولا يدري ان الليالي
حبالا سيعجل التباخ بريغوجين كل عناصر
تجربته كمجرم ورجل اعمال وصاحب شبكه
علاقات مع كبار المسؤولين ليصنع شركه
امنيه سيكون لها صيت اي صيت في روسيا
وخارج
انها فاجنر مالكه البنادق المستاجره للقتل
بنادق تحرس السلطات الايله للسقوط من ان
تسقط في سوريا وفي عدد من الدول الافريقيه
من بينها افريقيا الوسطى ومالي في ليبيا
ستجد فاغنر في صف اللواء المتقاعد حليف
حفتر تتكسب من القتال معه ومن حراسه ابار
النفط تحت
سيطرته في السودان اسمه فاغنر ارتبط بقوات
الدعم السريع
وبالتنفيس
كانت حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا او ما يسميها
بوتن بالعمليه العسكريه الخاصه هي
المناسبه التي ستجعل اسم فاغنر مرادفا
للتعبير عن الوطنيه والتضحيات الكبيره من
اجل الوطن وذلك بما احدث جنود فاجنر من
تحول كبير في سير العمليات العسكريه خاصه
في مدينه باخ موت لكن لحظه الصعود الى
القمه كان كانت هي عينها لحظه الاندفاع
الى السفح انقلب بريجين على الجيش الروسي
واوسع قادته سبا وشتما ولعنا وقال انهم
خذلوه في ارض المعركه ولم يكتفوا بعدم مده
بالاسلحه والذخائر بل قتلوا جنوده كذلك
ويمضي بريغوجين ابعد من ذلك فيصف الحرب
على اوكرانيا بالعار ثم يصل الى النقطه
الخطره التي لا عوده بعدها وهي التمرد على
الجيش الروسي في الثال من يونيو حزيران
الماضي فامر جنوده بالزحف على العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو للانتقام من قياده القوات
الروسيه وقال انهم ضللوا الرئيس وانهم
وراء الاداء المتواضع للجيش الروسي في
الحرب لكن الزحف على موسكو يتوقف فجاه
باتفاق سعى فيه الرئيس البيلاروسي
الكساندر لوكاشينكو بين الكرملين وبين
فاغنر تم بموجبه انها التمرد واسقاط
العقوبه عن يفجيني بريغوجين
وجنوده كثيرون قالوا ان يفجيني بريغوجين
قد حرر شهاده وفاته بيده يوم تمرد على
الرئيس بوتين بعد شهرين من ذلك التمرد
ستهوي طائره افجين بريجين عموديا الى
الارض منهيه حياته وحياه رفيقه دمتري
اتكين الشخصيه الثانيه من حيث الاهميه
داخل
فاجنر لما هوت الطائره وهل فجرت ام اسقطت
هل كان تدبيرا ام كان حادثا لا يد لاحد
فيه اسئله لي ماط اللثام عن سرها قريبا
ربما وما مصير فاجنر بعد مصرع زعيمها في
تحليل بنيه المليشيا ان تماسكها مرتبط الى
حد كبير بزعيم فان اختفى تفرغ جمعها خاصه
اذا كان ذلك القائد كيف جين بريغوجين
وخاصه اذا كانت الميليشيا بلا مشروع
ايديولوجي وكان دافعها الى القتال هو
الكسب المادي بوتين ولا احد غيره هو من
سيقول للعالم ان يف جين بريغوجين قد لقي
حتفه يعزي اسرته ويذكره ببعض خير ثم يصدر
الستار انتهى
التمرد وفي ردود الفعل بشان تحطم طائره
برجوج قال رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
المشتركه مارك ميلي ان بلاده لا علاقه لها
على الاطلاق بتحطم طائره بريغوجين مضيفا
ان مقتل بريغوجين ستكون له تداعيات في
مناطق وجود فاغنر في العالم كما قال
المسؤول العسكري الامريكي انه لم يفاجا
بسقوط طائره قائد فاغنر وان تمرد بريغوجين
عرضه
للخطر قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه بات رايدر ان تقييم بلاده
الاولي يشير الى ان بريغوجين قد قتل اضاف
رايدر في مؤتمر صحفي ان التقارير الصحفيه
بشان تعرض الطائره لصاروخ ارض جو غير
دقيقه تقييمنا الاولي يشير الى ان من
المحتمل ان بريغوجين قد قتل ونواصل تقييم
الوضع التقارير الصحفيه بشان تعرض الطائره
لصاروخ ارض جو غير دقيقه وفق تقييمنا ولا
شيء يشير الى حصول
ذلك ما هو مصير فاغنر سؤال بات ملحا لكنه
يتجاوز الجانب المعروف من انشطه فاجنر الى
امبراطوريه من الشركات داخل وخارج روسيا
تعمل جميعها في اطار شركه كونكورد القابضه
التي اسسها يفجيني بريغوجين التفاصيل في
التقرير
التالي ما يعرف عن يفجيني بريغوجين
وانشطته العسكريه والتجاريه اقل بكثير مما
يبقى طي ملفات اجهزه الامن الروسيه
والغربيه فاجنر هي اللغز الاشهر شركه
امنيه تضم الاف المقاتلين يعرف القليل عن
هيكلها التنظيمي اسسها دميتري اوتك الضابط
السابق في الجيش الروسي مع بريغوجين
ويعتبر فاليري تيكال المسؤوله الوحيده عن
تنظيم تحركات
يوجن السؤال راهنا ما هو هو مصير فاغنر
منذ حزيران يونيو الماضي ومع تمرد
بريغوجين تردد اسم اندري تروشي مرشحا
مفضلا لدى دوائر القرار في موسكو لقياده
فاغنر تروشي هو كولونيل روسي متقاعد عمل
في فرقه الاستجابه السريعه الخاصه بوزاره
الداخليه الروسيه شارك في حربي الشيشان
وافغانستان عضو مؤسس ومدير تنفيذي لمجموعه
فاغنر تعرفه وفائق عقوبات الاتحاد
الاوروبي الصادره نهايه عام
2021 بانه رئيس اركان عمليات فاغنر في
سوريا وعلى غرار بريغوجين يحمل تروشي اعلى
وسام عسكري بوصفه بطلا قوميا روسيا لكن
وراء فاجنر تقف شركه كونكورد القابضه
اسسها يف جيدي بريغوجين عام
1995 وكان يملك نصف اسهم الشركه حتى عام
2009 لتنتقل ملكيتها رسميا بعد ذلك
لوالدته فيوليتا بريغوجين
تحولت كونكورد لشركه قابضه وتنوعت اعمال
بريغوجين شركات امنيه وتموين وانشاءات
ووسائل اعلام تملك اسهما في عده شركات
منها ميغ لااين وهي شركه انشاءات تعاقدت
مع الجيش الروسي نورث فيرساي وهي شركه
تطوير عقاري في سان بترسبورغ اجات شركه
تجاريه تعمل في مجالات وسائل النقل وتمتد
اذرع كونكورد بحسب الاتحاد الاوروبي خارج
روسيا منها افرو بوليس التي تعمل على
حراسه حقول غاز في سوريا بروكر اكسبرت
وتعمل على التنقيب في مناجم ذهب بالسودان
باروج التي تمتلك امتيازا للخشب احمر في
جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى وتسيطر شركه ميداس
ريسورسز على انتاج مناجم ذهب في افريقيا
الوسطى ايضا وتتولى ديم فيل تصدير الذهب
والماس المستخرج من الدوله
[موسيقى]
عينها ينضم الينا من واشنطن الدكتور
دونالد جنسن مدير شؤون روسيا والاستقرار
الاستراتيجي في معهد الولايات المتحده
للسلام دكتور دونالد جنسن باي عين تراقب
الولايات المتحده والسلطات في الولايات
المتحده ما يحدث في موسكو ومقتل يفجيني
بريوش اعتقد ان رد الفعل الاساسي كان
المفاجاه منذ التمرد في شهر يونيو وضعوا
الموضوع جانبا وكانوا يتسائلون اذا كان
بوتين
قد ضعف ولكن الامور تغيرت بعد موت
بيكوجين بدا الناس يسالون اذا كان موت
بريغوجين يؤثر
على سلطه بوتين وكيف سيؤثر ذلك على ملف
اوكرانيا الاعلام في واشنطن اليوم يتحدث
عن ان بعض قوات فاجنر تغادر بيلاروسيا
طبعا هذا
يخفف من تهديد فاجنر في
بيلاروسيا لدينا عنصر المفاجاه ولكن بصوره
اساسيه بالرغم من عنصر المفاجاه هذا اي
شيء متوقع من النظام الفتاك في روسيا كثر
يقولون كنا نتوقع ذلك حين هدد اذا بوتين
بوجن بنهايه شهر يونيو في السعات الماضيه
دكتور دونالد جنسن جرى يعني كانت هناك
روايات متعدده جرى تناقلها لما حدث في
الولايات المتحده نقلا عن مسؤولين
امريكيين الى ان خرج المتحدث با البنتاجون
وقال انه لا يمكن ترجيح فرضيه على اخرى
كيف يفهم ذلك ماذا
وراءه بكل
بساطه الحكومه الامريكيه ليست اكيده مما
حصل مثلا الاعلام الامريكي اليوم تحدث عما
اذا كان تم اسقاط الطائره من خلال تفجير
او من خلال صاروخ لا اعرف ما تمتلكه
الاداره الامريكيه من معلومات ولكن عنصر
المفاجاه
ساد بعد سنه ونصف من الحرب في اوكرانيا
راينا كل الفضائ التي ارتكبتها القوات
الروسيه وبالتالي الكثير من المراقبين في
الولايات المتحده لا سما في واشنطن يعرف
السجل الاسود لفاجنر في اوكرانيا وبالتالي
هم يتوقعون اي شيء هذا اولا ثانيا لقد
صعقوا
بسلوكيات وتصرفات فاغنر في اوكرانيا لا
سما طبعا الحوادث المروعه لا سما في بخم
طبعا ودور قوات فاغنر الاساسي فيها ولكن
من بين الامور التي لم تذكر
ب نفس ال
هو اذا تاثير مجموعه فاجنر ب معاملها
الالكترونيه
على المؤسسات الحكوميه الغربيه
ولكن اليوم بدات الصوره تتوضح اكثر من قبل
نحن نترقب ننتظر ما سيحصل ولكن بصوره
اساسيه نتساءل عن تاثير ذلك على حكم
بوتين هل هذا يقويه او يضعفه
انا اعتقد ان ذلك سوف يقويه وانا لا اتوقع
ان تكون هذه اخر
حادثه انت تقول ان ما حدث ربما سيقوي
بوتين ولكن البنتاجون يتحدث عن تداعيات
على عمل فاجنر في مناطق نفوذها ما هذه
التداعيات التي يمكن
توقعها
اولا انا كنت اقصد ان هذا يضعف بوتين بطرق
مختلفه
فهو سيكون عليه ان يحاول بط سيطرته مره
اخرى على النظام بعدما كانت فاجنر هي التي
تتولى هذا
الموضوع اذا لا يجب ان نفصل ذلك عما حدث
من قبل ولكن ما سنشهد هو ان بوتين سوف
يحاول ان يعيد السيطره على النظم ظ في
روسيا ان يظهر انه هو المسؤول وان الجميع
يجب ان يعود اليه هناك الكثير من العوامل
التي تضغط على بوتين وعلى النظام الروسي
حتى يتمكن من السيطره على كل هذه الجوانب
بعد 20 اكثر من 20 عاما في السلطه كثر من
المراقبين في واشنطن ايضا يترقبون ذلك
شكرا لك الدكتور دونالد جنسن مدير شؤون
روسيا والاستقرار الاستراتيجي في معهد
الولايات المتحده للسلام من
[موسيقى]
واشنطن قال المتحدث باسم المخابرات
الاوكرانيه يوسوف ان عمليه الانزال الخاصه
التي نفذتها المخابرات الاوكرانيه
بالتعاون مع القوات البحريه في شبه جزيره
القرم الليله الماضيه اسفرت عن مقتل 30
جنديا روسيا وتدمير اربعه زوارق روسيه
تزمن الاعلان عن هذه العمليه مع احتفال
اوكرانيا بذكرى عيد
الاستقلال يحتفل الاوكرانيين بالذكرى الان
لاستقلال بلادهم اجواء الحرب تغلف
الاحتفال
في كل مكان هو العيد الثاني منذ بدء الحرب
قبل اكثر من 18 شهرا في هذه الذكرى اختار
الاوكرانيين تنفيذ عمليه خاصه في مكان له
رمزيه خاصه بالنسبه اليهم تقول المخابرات
الاوكرانيه ان قوات البحريه والمخابرات
العسكريه نفذت عمليه خاصه وانزلت قوات
غربيه في جزيره القرم قرب اولينكا ومايا
ورفعت العلم الاوكراني حسب اندري يوسوف
المتحدث باسم المخابرات الاوكرانيه فقد
نفذت القوات الاوكرانيه كل المهام والحقت
خسائر بقوات روسيه اشتبكت معها ثم انسحبت
من موقع الانزال في المقابل تقول وسائل
اعلام روسيه نقلا عن المخابرات الروسيه ان
الاوكرانيين استخدموا اربعه زوارق مطاطيه
في عمليه الانزال التي شارك فيها ما بين
15 و2 رجلا تم القضاء عليهم جميعا يعد هذا
الانزال تطورا نوعيا في الحرب الدائره
حاليا ففي الفتره الاخيره استهدفت القوات
الاوكرانيه شبه الجزيره بمسيرات جويه
وبحريه وركزت على مقر اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي في سيفاستوبول وتعد هذه المره
الاولى التي يصل فيها جنود اوكرانيون الى
شبه الجزيره منذ ضمها من قبل روسيا عام
2014 وربطها باليابسه الروسيه عبر جسر
كيرتش عام
2018 ترفض موسكو مجرد الحديث عن التخلي عن
شبه الج الزيره لكن كيف مصره على
استعادتها في الخطاب الذي وجهه الرئيس
الاوكراني لشعبه في ذكرى عيد الاستقلال
كانت القرم حاضره وعاد فلودمير زيلينسكي
بتحرير شبه الجزيره مما وصفه بالاحتلال
الروسي وطالب الاوكرانيين بان لا يفقدوا
الامل وهم يواجهون ظروفا صعبه لم تختفي
الظروف الصعبه في يوم الاحتفال بعيد
الاستقلال قال حاكم دنيبرو ان قصفا
صاروخيا روسيا استهدف المدينه وخلف عشره
جرح على الاقل وتعرضت خيرسون لقصف روسي
والحق قصف اخر اضرارا كبيره بمحطه
للكهرباء لتستمر حرب الاستنزاف بين
[موسيقى]
الطرفين اعلن البيت الابيض ان مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي جيك سليفن عقد
اجتماعا خماسيا مع نظرائه من فرنسا
والمانيا وايطاليا والمملكه المتحده وقال
البيت الابيض ان مستشاري الامن القومي
لدول الخمس شددوا على اهميه اعاده النيجر
الى طريق النظام الدستوري ودعم الدور
القيادي لمجموعه ايكواس اضاف ان مستشاري
الامن القومي اكدوا مواصله دعم بلدانهم
لاوكرانيا للتصدي للهجوم الروسي مهما
استغرق الامر ومساعدتها في اعاده
الاعمار التقى رئيس الوزراء معين من
المجلس العسكري في النيجير وفدا جزائريا
وصل الى العاصمه نيامي ويبحث الوفد مع
الحكومه سبل حل الازمه في النيجر وتجنيب
البلاد التدخل العسكري الذي تهدد به
مجموعه ايكواس في حال امتناع قاده الجيش
عن اعاده السلطه الى الرئيس محمد بازوم في
الاثناء يزور وزير الخارجيه الجزائري احمد
عطاف كلا من نيجيريا وغانا لعرض موقف
بلاده الرافض للتدخل العسكري والسعي
لايجاد حل سلمي
للازمه قال عبد السلام ابو بكر رئيس
نيجيريا السابق ورئيس وفد ايكواس للتفاوض
مع المجلس العسكري في النيجير ان رئيس
المجلس العسكري عبد الرحمن تياني رفض طلب
الوفد اعاده الرئيس محمد بازوم الى منصبه
اضاف رئيس وفد ايكواس في تصريحات ان تياني
قال ان اطلاق سراح الرئيس بازوم ممكن اذا
تم التفاهم على ذلك لكنه لن يعود للسلطه
كما اكد ان مده الفتره الانتقاليه هي ثلاث
سنوات وطالب بفتح الحدود المغلقه واعاده
الكهرباء الى
نيجر وكان رئيس ما يطلق على ما يطلق على
نفسه المجلس الوطني لحمايه الوطن في
النيجر عبد الرحمن تياني التقى وفدا من
علماء نيجيريا وكان الوفد الذي يراسه
الشيخ عبد الله بلالو قد وصل الاربعاء الى
نيا واجتمع مع تياني في ثاني زياره له منذ
الاطاحه بالرئيس محمد بزوم وكان المجلس قد
رحب في وقت سابق بواسطه وفد علماء نيجيريا
لانهاء الازمه السياسيه في
[موسيقى]
النيجير اختتمت قمه مجموعه لبريكس في جنوب
افريقيا اعلان حمل اسم مدينه جوهانسبرج
وتضمن الموافقه على ترشيح ست دول اخرى
للانضمام الى التكتل والدول التي فتح لها
باب الدخول دخول البريكس رسميا هي
السعوديه والامارات وايران واثيوبيا
والارجنتين بدء من يناير
المقبل صوره اعضاء البريكس ستكون اوسع بعد
يناير المقبل التكتل السداسي الذي يجمع
الاضاض وفقط في قمه جوهانسبورغ على ترشيح
ست دول اخرى للانضمام اليه رسميا بعد
شهور في اي سياق جيوسياسي عالمي انزعت
الموافقه وماذا سيضيف الاعضاء الجدد من
اصل 2 دوله اعربت عن رغبتها في دخول بيت
البريكس تقرر الان قبول الست والاخريات
على قائمه الانتظار حظيت بشرف الدخول
السعوديه وايران والامارات ومصر واثيوبيا
والارجنتين بذلك سيصبح التكتل الان
46% من سكان العالم وبالاصل تضم المجموعه
اكثر من ثلاثه مليارات نسمه اي
42% من سكان العالم واكثر من
16% من التجاره العالميه ومجموع احتياطي
النقد الاجنبي يصل 4 ترليونات
دولار بعيدا عن عدسات الكاميرات وخطابات
المجامله بين الحضور كان ثمه انقسام بشان
معايير واليه انضمام الاعضاء الجدد القمه
التي حضرها نحو 50 رئيسا ورئيس حكومه
وصفها رئيس البلد المضيف سيري رم فوزه
بالتاريخ وبالنسبه لوزير خارجيه السعوديه
المبادئ المشتركه هي ما يجمع المملكه
بالتكتل ان العلاقه الاستراتيجيه المتميزه
بيندول مجموعه بريكس تعزز عطر المبادئ
المشتركه ومن ابرزها الايمان الراسخ بما
احترام سياده الدول واستقلالها وعدم
التدخل في شؤونها والتمسك بمبادئ القانون
الدولي وتسويه النزاعات بالطرق السلميه
دخول البريكس تعتبره طهران خروجا اخر من
عزله تسع واشنطن لفرضها عليها وتوسيعها
اكثر وصفه اكثر من مسؤول ايراني بالنجاح
الاستراتيجي للسياسه الخارجيه للجمهوريه
الاسلاميه في مواجهه عالم احادي القطب عن
العالم الجديد المطلوب
تحدث الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي
تلاش بريكس هي منظمه يمكن ان تساهم في حل
مشاكل العالم خصوصا بعد ان فتحت القمه
الباب امام مجموعه من الدول للانضمام الى
التكتل الذي سيساعد على بناء عالم متعدد
الاقطاب التكتل الذي يضم دولا صديقه وخصما
للولايات المتحده هل سينجح في تغيير خريطه
التوازنات والتحالفات في العالم والى اي
مدى تقلل واشنطن على الاقل علنا من احتمال
ان تشكل المجموعه منافسا جيوسياسيا مساله
توحيد العمله والاستقلال عن الدولار
الامريكي لم تحسم في قمه جوهانسبرج التي
دامت ثلاثه ايام ليس سرا ان تسعير النفط
بعملات اخرى غير الدولار هو اكبر مصدر قلق
لواشنطن التنوع الاقتصادي والسياسي داخل
البريكس هل سيكون نقطه قوه تمهد لعالم لا
تهيمن عليه الولايات المتحده والقوى
التقليديه الاخرى ام سيكون نقطه ضعف امام
امنيات ونيات من اجل عالم متعدد الاقطاب
فعلا ولكن ماذا لو كان مفهوم تعدد الاقطاب
يختلف من عضو الى اخر داخل
المجموعه
[موسيقى]
من المتوقع ان يسلم الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب نفسه اليوم الى سجن
مقاطعه فولتن بولايه جورجيا تنفيذا لطلب
المدعيه العامه في المقاطعه ضمن القضيه
المتعلقه بنتائج انتخابات 2020 في الولايه
ويواجه ترامب 13 تهمه بينها التامر
والتضليل وتقديم شهادات ووثائق مزوره
اضافه الى ممارسه ضغوط غير قانونيه تغيير
نتائج الانتخابات لصالحه وسلم تسعه متهمين
انفسهم للسجن ذاته ونشرت سلطات المقاطعه
صورهم ويتوقع ان تفعل الامر نفسه مع ترامب
ونقلت شبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه عن مصادر
قولها ان الرئيس السابق ترامب قرر تغيير
كبار محاميه قبل ساعات من تسليم نفسه
لسلطات
السجن مستمرون معكم في حصاد هذه الليله
وهذا ابرز
العناوين بعد نحو 24 ساعه من الغموض تاكد
مقتل قائد فاجنر بوتين يعزي عائله يفجيني
بريغوجين يشيد بقائد فاجنر ويقول انه
ارتكب اخطاء ويكشف انه اجتمع بمسؤولين في
موسكو قبل حادث تحطم
طائراته بعد زيلينسكي قائد القوات
الامريكيه المشتركه يقول ان واشنطن لا
علاقه لها باستهداف طائره بريغوجين تقارير
استخباريه ريكيه تتحدث عن احتمال تفجيرها
من الداخل والبنتاجون ينفي فرضيه قصفها
بصاروخ ويقول ان مجموعه فاغنر تمثل تهديدا
حقيقيا وان نشاطها في افريقيا
سيراقب لاول مره منذ ضم روسيا لشبه جزيره
القرم القوات الاوكرانيه تعلن تنفيذ عمليه
انزال في شبه الجزيره وتقول انها قتلت 30
جنديا روسيا و ئل اعلام روسيه تنقل عن
مخابرات موسكو ان عمليه الانزال افشلت
بقتل جميع الجنود
المشاركين حراك يتسارع بشان انقلاب النيجر
مستشارو الامن القومي في الولايات المتحده
ودول اوروبيه يشددون في اجتماع على اعاده
النظام الدستوري وزيرا خارجيه مالي
وبوركينا فاسو في نيامي بالتزامن مع زياره
مسؤول جزائري ووفد علماء نيجيريا يقول انه
يسعى للحصول على التزامات من قاده
[موسيقى]
الانقلاب قدم الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين التعازي لعائله يفجيني بريغوجين ملك
شركه فاجنر وقال بوتين خ خلال لقاء مع
رئيس دونيتسك الموالي لروسيا دينس بوشيلين
انه عرف بريغوجين منذ تسعينيات القرن
الماضي كرجل اعمال
موهوب فيما يتعلق بهذه الماسات الجويه اود
اولا ان اقدم خالص التعازي لاسر الضحايا
انها ماسات اذا كان ضمن الركاب موظف شركه
فاجنر والبيانات الاوليه تشير الى وجودهم
فاود الاشاره الى ان هؤلاء الاشخاص قدموا
مساهمه كبيره في قضيتنا المشتركه المتمثله
في محار نظام النازيين الجدد في اوكرانيا
نحن ندرك ذلك ولن ننساه عرفت بريغوجين منذ
فتره طويله منذ بدايات تسعينيات القرن
الماضي لقد كان مصير الرجل معقدا كانت له
اخطاء كثيره في حياته وحقق نتائج مهمه له
ول الاور المشتركه كما في الاشهر الاخيره
كان شخصا موهوبا ورجل اعمال موهوبا وليس
في روسيا فحسب لقد حقق نتائج في افريقيا
حيث كان يع في مجال النفط والغاز والمعادن
والاحجار النفيسه اخر المعلومات تشير الى
انه وصل امس فقط من افريقيا والتقى هنا
ببعض الشخصيات الرسميه رئيس لجنه التحقيق
ابلغني اليوم بانهم بداوا بالفعل تحقيقا
اوليا في هذا الحادث وسينفذ بالكامل دعونا
نرى ما سيقوله المحققون في المستقبل
القريب الان تجرى الفحوصات الفنيه
والوراثيه وهذا سيستغرق بعض
الوقت
من محيط موقع تحطم الطائره في بلده كوجين
كينو شمال غرب موسكو ينضم الينا مراسل
الجزيره امين درغامي امين ضعنا في صوره ما
يحدث في موقع تحطم الطائره واخر مستجدات
التحقيق نعم السي انسحبت المزيد من
السيارات التابعه لمختلف اجهزه الامن
الروسيه سواء من الامن الفيدرالي جهاز
الامن الفيدرالي او لجنه التحقيق او حتى
وزاره الداخليه من مكان تحطم هذه الطائره
عبر دفعات فيما يبدو انه توقف لعمليات
البحث والتحقيق في مكان تحطم هذه الطائره
على ان تستمر كما جرى الليله الماضيه صباح
يوم غد طبعا في ما يخص تلك الاسئله
المعلقه التي كان كانت حول ما جرى
وتحديدا المتعلقه بمصير الصندوقين
الاسودين حتى الان لم تصدر اي تصريحات عن
لجنه التحقيق
الفيدراليه بشان هل تم العثور على
الصندوقين الاسودين ام لا في انتظار ان
تكتمل هذه التحقيقات على الاقل الاوليه
وكما كان الرئيس طبعا الروسي ايضا قد قاله
بان هناك مرحله اولى بداتها لجنه التحقيق
الفيدراليه في ملابسات الحادث هذه المنطقه
مغلقه لا يتم السماح لاي احد بالوصول او
الاقتراب حتى من منطقه تحطم هذه الطائره
لعده اسباب اولها عدم التشويش على
المحققين ثم ان بعض اجزاء هذه الطائره
تطايره في منطقه يصل قطرها الى نحو
كيلومترين ونصف بعض اجزاء الطائره عثر
عليها في منطقه تبعد عن منطقه
سقوط جسم الطائره الرئيسي بنحو كيلومترين
ونصف وبالتالي كل
هذا قد يساعد المحققين في جمع الادله
وترتيب ما تم الحصول عليه وجمعه من مكان
تحطم هذه الطائره من اجل ان تتضح الصوره
وتكتمل خلال الايام لربما المقبله بخصوص
ملابسات هذا الحادث طبعا كانت هناك
تصريحات ولو على قلتها بعد ان اكد الرئيس
بوتين على ان بريغوجين كان ضمن القتلى
العشره الذين كانوا على متن هذه الطائره
من طراز امبراير
135 التابعه لملك شركه فاجنر يفجيني
بريغوجين هذا تصريح صدر قبل قليل عن على
لسان وزير الخارجيه سيرجي لافروف من على
هامش اعمال قمه بريكس في جنوب افريقيا و
حول سؤال عما تم تداوله على مستوى بعض
وسائل الاعلام الغربيه دعا الى التريث
وانتظار انتهاء التحقيقات والتركيز فقط
على الحقائق كما قال وليس على ما تبثه
وسائل الاعلام الغربيه وهذه التصريحات
بطبيعه الحال تتقاطع اذا صح التعبير
وتتناغم مع الموقف الرسمي الذي يبدو انه
متريث الى حد كبير وا في بعض
لربما اجزاء هذه القضيه متحفظ اكثر ولربما
من اجل السماح للجنه التحقيق باكمال عملها
دون اعطاء اي استنتاجات مسبقه هذا ايضا
موقف شركه فاغنر الذي كانت امس قد عبرت
عنه بانها ليس لديها اي تخمينات بشان
اسباب تحطم هذه الطائره ومقتل يفجيني
بريغوجين وبالتالي الانظار تتجه في
المرحله المقبله اولا سي عن الى مساله
مصير الصندوقين الاسودين ثم الى حطام
الطائره الذي مازال موجود في المنطقه التي
تحطمت فيها متى سيتم نقل هذه الاجزاء الى
لربما مطار قريب من هنا من اجل تجميعها و
استيضاح ما تعرضت له هذه الطائره قبل
سقوطها وهناك طبعا فرضيات كثيره طر حت
مبنيه على بعض الحقائق التي جرى تسجيلها
هنا انطلاقا من تصريحات شهود عيان حينما
قالوا بانهم سمعوا دوي انفجارين قبيل تحطم
هذه الطائره او الى بعض الصور التي اظهرت
بان الطائره تصاعد منها الدخان وهي في
طريقها الى الارتطام بالارض وكانت قد فقدت
احد جناحيها وبالتالي كل هذا يفتح الباب
امام تساؤلات ك كبيره عنما جرى خلال
اللحظات الاخيره قبل تحطم الطائره طبعا
وهذا ما ستجيب عنه بكل تاكيد التحقيقات
خلال الايام المقبله شكرا لك مراسلنا امين
درغامي من بلده كوجين كينو من محيط موقع
تحطم الطائره
شكرا بعد صمت طال كثيرا واثار فوضه
التخمينات حول مصير يفجيني بريغوجين مالك
مجموعه فاجنر خرج الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
ليؤكد مقتله في حادث تح طائرته يتقدم
بوتين بالتعزيه لاسرته ويقول انه يعرفه
منذ التسعينيات رجل اعمال ناجحا اسدى
خدمات لروسيا يقول بوتين ذلك ربما رعايه
لذكريات وربما دفعا لتهم تنهال عليه
بالوقوف وراء مقتل بريغوجين بسبب تمرده
عليه اختفاء بريغوجين يثير اسئله حول مصير
فاغنر التي تبيع القتل مقابل المال وتصنع
لروسيا نفوذا لا لم تتمكن الدوله من
تحقيقه في العالم لا سما في افريقيا تقرير
فوزي
بشرى مشهد للقوه للسلطه في تمام تجلياتها
لا يحتمل خدشا بمعارض كتومه او فصيحه لا
يحتمل منازعه عليها او تشكيكا فيها لكن
رجلا تجرا في لحظه سكره بقوته ونفوذه
وبغير قليل من الاجراء على الكرملين ان
يحدث نفسه بختش هذه الصوره صوره بوتين
وصوره الجيش الروسي الذي يخوض حربا ضروسا
ضد اوكرانيا لم يكن ذلك الرجل احدا غير
افجين بريجين انه السجين السابق الذي امضى
في السجن تسع سنوات من اصل عقوبه بلغت ا
عش سنه بسبب فساده واحتيال
وسرقاته يبلغ بريغوجين نهايه طموحه في
اعمال المطاعم وصناعه الطعام ويتحول الى
متعهد لعدد من المناسبات الرسميه في
الكرملين حتى لحق به لقب طباخ الرئيس يرد
بريغوجين اليط اللسان يمكن ان اسمى بدقه
اكثر جزار الرئيس ولا يدري ان الليالي
حبالا سيعجل التباخ بريغوجين كل عناصر
تجربته كمجرم ورجل اعمال وصاحب شبكه
علاقات مع كبار المسؤولين ليصنع شركه
امنيه سيكون لها صيت اي صيت في روسيا
وخارجها انها فاجنر ملكه البنادق
المستاجره للقتل بنادق تحرس السلطات
الايله للسقوط من ان تسقط في سوريا وفي
عدد من الدول الافريقيه من بينها افريقيا
الوسطى ومالي في ليبيا ستجد ذ فاغنر في صف
اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر تتكسب من
القتال معه ومن حراسه ابار النفط تحت
سيطرته في السودان اسم فاغنر ارتبط بقوات
الدعم السريع
وبتنقل
وحراسته كانت حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا او
ما يسميها بوتين بالعمليه العسكريه الخاصه
هي المناسبه التي ستجعل اسم فاجنر مرادفا
للتعبير عن الوطنيه والتضحيات الكبيره من
اجل الوطن وذلك بما احدث جنود فاغنر من
تحول كبير في سير العمليات العسكريه خاصه
في مدينه باخ موت لكن لحظه الصعود الى
القمه كانت هي عينها لحظه الاندفاع الى
السفح انقلب بريجين على الجيش الروسي
واوسع قادته سبا وشتما ولعنا وقال انهم
خذلوه في ارض المعركه ولم يكتفوا بعدم مده
بالاسلحه والذخائر بل قتلوا جنوده كذلك
ويمضي بريغوجين ابعد من ذلك فيصف الحرب
على اوكرانيا
بالعار ثم يصل الى النقطه الخطره التي لا
عوده بعدها وهي اعلانه التمرد على الجيش
الروسي في الث3 من يونيو حزيران الماضي
فامر جنوده بالزحف على العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو للانتقام من قياده القوات الروسيه
وقال انهم ضللوا الرئيس وانهم وراء الاداء
المتواضع للجيش الروسي في الحرب
لكن الزحف على موسكو يتوقف فجاه باتفاق
سعى فيه الرئيس البيلاروسي الكساندر
لوكاشينكو بين الكرملين وبين فاجنر تم
بموجبه انهاء التمرد واسقاط العقوبه عن
يفجيني بريغوجين
وجنوده كثيرون قالوا انجين بريغوجين قد
حرر شهاده وفاته بيده يوم تمرد على الرئيس
بوتين بعد شهرين من ذلك التمرد ستهوي
طائره وجين بريجين عموديا الى الارض منهيه
حياته وحياه رفيقه ديمتري اتكين الشخصيه
الثانيه من حيث الاهميه داخل فاجنر لما
هوت الطائره وهل فجرت ام اسقطت هل كان
تدبيرا ام كان حادثا لا يد لاحد فيه اسئله
ليي ماط اللثام عن سرها قريبا ربما وما
مصير فاجنر بعد مصرع زعيمها في تحليل بنيه
المليشيا تماسكها مرتبط الى حد كبير بزعيم
فان اختفى تفرغ جمعها خاصه اذا كان ذلك
القائد كيف جين بريغوجين
وخاصه اذا كانت الميليشيا بلا مشروع
ايديولوجي وكان دافعها الى القتال هو
الكسب المادي بوتين ولا احد غيره هو من
سيقول للعالم ان يف جين بريغوجين قد لقي
حتفه يعزي اسرته ويذكره ببعض خير ثم يسدر
الستار انتهى
التمرد ينضم الينا من موسكو سيرجي روكان
محرر الشؤون الدوليه بصحيفه كوميرسانت
والباحث في المجلس الروسي للشؤون الدوليه
ومعنا من موسكو فاديم كوزول استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في اكاديميه العلوم العسكريه
مرحبا بكما سيد سيرجي روكان سابدا معك
زميلنا فوزي بشرى فصل لنا ب
يعني بالتفصيل مسار العلاقه بين بوتين
وبريو من التقارب الى التمرد الذي حدث قبل
شهرين في ضوء ذلك ما حقيقه شعور المسؤولين
الروس اليوم والرئيس بوتين تحديدا حيال
مقتل بريغوجين
دعوني ابدا من السيد بوتين اليوم حتى نقوم
بالغاء اي حديث عن بوتين اعلن رسميا السيد
الرئيس حيث قال انه وضح عن علاقته بالسيد
بريغوجين ونظرته لمجموعات فاجنر وسمعت
لهذا الاعلان من الرئيس وكان عاطفيا
وكان واضحا مشاعر
الاسف عن ما حدث بغض نظر عن ان بريغوجين
حاول القيام بتمرد ضد روسيا ولكن بوتين لم
يتحدث باي
كلمه باي كلمه تسيء لبوج ولكنه قال انه
قام باخطاء واخطاء كبيره ولكن حسب ما فهمت
كلمه السيد الرئيس بشكل عام قيم ارث هذا
الشخص
بعلامه بعلامه ايجابيه و
قال انه بغض النظر عن علاقه الكثيرين ل
بريغوجين ولكنه كان شخصا وطني وفاغنر قامت
بدور مهم في اثناء العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه ضد اوكرانيا
وقام بوتين باظهار احترامه لمقاتلين فاجنر
بهذه الطريقه نرى علاقه الرئيس اما النخبه
السياسيه الروسيه من الممكن ان اقول ان
هناك تضارب في الاراء وانا ايضا اتحدث
مع مع اشخاص اجتماعيه وسياسيين والاراء
متضاربه لان شخصيه بريغوجين هي متضاربه
ايضا بالطبع لا نستطيع ان نغض النظر عن
نجاحاته وانه قد كرم بوسام نجمه روسيا
وكان بطلا واعماله كانت قد قدرت على اعلى
المستويات ولكن من جانب اخر وهذا شيء لا
يقل اهميه
ان تصرفات بريغوجين واعمال شركتها
العسكريه الخاصه
تجعلنا نعتقد انه كان يقوم باعمال غير
قانونيه بالنسبه لروسيا وهذا شيء مهم جدا
ان نفهمه كان جيشا في داخل جيش وكان يحاول
ان يكون دوله في داخل دوله في وفي هذا
الضوء اعمال ممكن ان تعتبر هدامه لروسيا
ولل الحكومه وللقانون الروسي
لان هذا شيء واوضاع غير مرغوبه وغير
متقبله عندما تقوم ادارات شركات عسكريه
خاصه بتوجيه التحديات للجيش النظامي سيديم
سيد فديم دعنا ناخذ ذلك الى السيد فاديم
كوزول سيد فاديم ضيفنا السيد سيرجي روكان
يقول ان بغض النظر عن التمرد يعبر الرئيس
الروسي عن الاسف والحزن ولكن هل يمكن فعلا
في سياق كل ما يجري غض النظر عن موضوع
التمرد الذي كان وصفه الرئيس الروسي بنفسه
على انه خيانه
عظمى يجب ان نفهم وندرك ان
هذا التمرد لم يكن ضد الدوله بل كان ضد
اشخاص معينين وقد تكون حركه عاطفيه وليس
من السليم ان ننظر لها كعمل استراتيجي
وهذا ما ينظر له المجتمع الروسي والاداره
الروسيه ايضا لذلك هذا التمرد هو لم يكن
تمردا على الدوله وحتى في بدايه هذا
التمرد قالج انني ادعم السيد بوتين
بكل قوه وانا جندي من جنوده وهذا لم يكن
في الواقع تمردا او خروجا على لكن كيف سي
سيد فديم كيف لا يكون تمردا ضد الدوله وهي
حركه كانت تتحدى الجيش الروسي والجيش يعني
رمز من رموز الدوله خصوصا في هذه الاثناء
وايضا كيف يمكن القول ان العلاقه لم تشبه
اي شيء
وكنا نشاهد الاعلام الروسي في الاسابيع
الماضيه يشيطن السيد بريغوجين
و يصوره على انه رجل فاسد لم يكن يقوم بما
هو يعني يتعين به ان يقوم يتعين ان يقوم
به كانت شخصيه متضاربه والكثير من
الخلافات كانت تجري عنه وماضيه كان مظلم
وكان لديه تاريخ
اجرامي
واعمال
تجاريه وكان
يتراس الشركه العسكريه الخاصه التي ممكن
ان نقول انها لم لا تتناسب مع القوانين
الداخليه الروسيه ان الشركات العسكريه
الخاصه في
هذا عمل اجرامي كما يعتبر قانونيا ولكن
روسيا في
ظروف تجعل المبادرات الخاصه شيء قيم جدا
وه هو بكل صراحه ما
حققه بريزن وادى الى احترام القياده له
والشعب ايضا
وهو كان مفيدا جدا في ظروف صعبه
لذلك كان هناك الكثير ما يسمح له حتى اكثر
من ما كان يستحق على اساس القانون الروسي
فلن ق انه كان قد تعدى وكان يرى هذا كان
يرى المستقبل وهذا ما
يناقشه في الداخل الروسي الان انه كان يجب
اتخاذ قوانين تقنن اوضاع الشركات العسكريه
الخاصه كان بريو ينقد القانون
وكان شخصيه ليست حكوميه ولكنه كان يقوم
بوظائف حكوميه لاجل الدوله ولاجل الشعب
وبهذا هذا كان قيمته وقدره وهذا هو دوره
الاساسي للدوله والحكومه لذلك كان شخصيه
خارجه عن او خارج اطار القانون وفي هذه
الظروف هذا الشيء هو قد استحقه بجد
واعتقد انه اليوم اصبح بطلا سوف يضعون له
المناصب التذكاريه وسوف تمجده الاجيال
القادمه سيد سيرجي روكان
باعتقادك اي تاثير سيكون لغياب مؤسسي
فاجنر
وزعيمها على هذه
الشركه
في
الواقع دعونا نقول ان هذه الكارثه كارثه
سقوط الطائره لم تقضي على بريغوجين فقط بل
على النائبه دميتري اتكن والقياده الاعلى
للمنظمه بشكل حقيقي هذه الشركه قد قطع
راسها
وفقدت القياده العليا وفي مجال تطبيق او
عملي
عمليا هذه القيادات
اختفت وبهذه الطريقه اختفت اساسات
الاستراتيجيات والدافع واختفى ايضا اختفت
الاهداف الاساسيه
والان قبل او امام هذه المنظمه هناك
طريقين اما ان تختفي عن الوجود كمنظمه او
انها يجب ان تعيد بناء نفسها من جديد ويجب
ان تظهر قيادات جديده من الممكن ان
يحاولوا ان لا يكرروا اخطاء بريغوجين وان
يستخدموا افضل ما في ارثه حتى يقدموا دافع
لحياه هذه الشركه العسكريه الخاصه فجنر
اما الدرب الثالث او الطريقه الثالثه هو
ان هذه التشكيلات ذات الخبره العسكريه قد
تندم
في صفوف وزاره الدفاع وهذا ما قد قدم
كعروض قبل التمرد وعندها سوف تبدا هذه
التشكيلات العسكريه بقيام بالقيام بدوري
الدفاع عن روسيا ليس تحت قبعه فاغنر بل في
اطار تشكيلات جديده لن يكون فيها هذا
النقد للقانون الواضح على اساس اعمال
الشركات العسكر الخاصه شكرا جزيلا لك
سيرجي روكان محرر الشؤون الدوليه بصحيفه
كوميرسانت والباحث المجلس الروسي للشؤون
الدوليه وشكرا للسيد فاديم كوزول لين
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في اكاديميه العلوم
العسكريه من
موسكو احتمالات عديده يمكن ان يكون احدها
سببا مباشرا لتحطم الطائره ويبقى ظهور
الحقيقه رهنا بما تقرر السلطات الروسيه
اعلانه بعد انتهاء التحقيقات لكننا في
التقرير التالي نستعرض اهم سيناريوهات
سقوط
الطائره هذا السقوط الذي رصدته عدسات
لطائره شركه فاجنر قد يعزز احتمالات دون
اخرى بشان السبب الحقيقي لكنه لا يجيب
بشكل حاسم عما ادى تحديدا لاسقاطها وعليها
ملك الشركه يفجيني بريغوجين يرى عسكريون
ان ثمه احتمالا من ثلاثه اما الخلل الفني
او الاستهداف من الداخل بقنبله مزروعه
سلفا او من الخارج بصاروخ قد استبعد فرضيه
الخلل الفني الذي ليس من شانه قطع الاتصال
مع قمره القياده ولا تغييب الطائره عن
شاشات الرادار بشكل فوري وهو ما وقع فعليا
بعد 26 دقيقه من الاقلاع كما تستبعد فرضيه
الخلل الفني لاستقرار معدل ارتفاع الطائره
وفق بيانات موقع فلايت رادار بشان احتمال
الاستهداف الخارجي فارتفاع الطائره لنحو 3
الف قدم يرجح استخدام صواريخ متوسطه او
بعيده المدى فهل استخدمت في تلك المناطق
المدنيه كما ان هذه الصواريخ لو اصابت جسم
الطائره فستفل ولن تسقط متماسكه كما ورد
في الصور لكن ماذا لو اصاب الصاروخ جناح
الطائره ففصل ل لتسقط بجناح واحد كما ذكر
شهود عيان احتمال قائم ينتظر التحقيقات
ويوضع في سياقه ايضا ما اورده خبراء حسب
معاينات اوليه حول ثقوب في جسم الطائره
ترجح اصابتها بصاروخ اما احتمال التفجير
الداخلي بقنبله فيبقى قائما وينتظر
تاكيدات فنيه حول موقع زرع القنبله ووزنها
وطريقه توجيهها وهل احدثت فجوه في جسم
الطائره اخلت بتوازنها لتسقط سريعا ام
فصرت الجزء الخلفي كما اورد تقرير لصحيفه
كوميرسانت الروسيه نقل عن خبراء في مجال
تحقيقات الكوارث الجويه اجابات تلك
الاسئله ما زالت حبيسه صندوقي الطائره
الاسودين اللذين تتوقف سرعه كشف ما فيهما
على قرار جهات التحقيق وعملها على
الارض ينضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس
حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك
عميد الياس حنا في ضوء المعلومات
والمعطيات التي توفرت حتى الان هل يمكن
الحديث عن سيناريو اكثر ترجيحا لما حدث
لهذه
الطائره السي الاحتمالات محدوده بناء على
المعلومات الموجوده اليوم عندما نتحدث عن
تفجير من الداخل وهذا امر تحدثنا عنه
البارحه على شاشه الجزيره التفجير من
الداخل ايضا
يتطلب تحقيق جنائي فورنسيك كما يقال يعني
يجب ان يذهب الخبراء الى هذه الطائره الى
بقايا واثار الطائره لاخذ عينات منها لانه
التفجير سيترك اثار اثار كيميائيه تؤخذ
الى المختبرات تفسر تحلل لمعرفه هل فعلا
هناك تفجير حتى من جسم الطائره يمكن ان
يعرف اذا كان هناك تفجير وما نوع هذه
المتفجرات ومن يملك هذه المتفجرات ومن
وضعها وكيف وضعها هل هو عامل الصيانه
الماجور او هل هي عمليه واسعه وشاس يعني
حتى عندما اتى في التقرير سقطت بجان واحد
قد تكون هذه ال التفجير من الداخل موضوع
في الجانح فاذا نحن امام مرحله ايه بسيطه
ولكن مرحله ضبابيه لا تزال هذا الامر
يتطلب وقتا طويلا صندوقي صندوق الاسود
مهمين ولكن هل فعلا سنعرف لاحقا السبب
الفعلي لسقوط الطائره الاس طيب من من
المعاينه من معاينتك للفيديوهات والصور
التي توفرت ما الذي يمكن ان يقال بشان
فرضيتين واحده تتحدث عن اي صاروخ ارض جو
يمكن ان يكون قد استهدف هذا هذه الطائره
واخرى تتحدث عن تفجير من داخل
الطائره السي جسم
الطائره سقط تقريبا كامل وفي خلفيه
الطائره او في ذنب الطائره هو الاشتعال
والدخان الاسود يعني اليوم عندما نتحدث عن
حتى يعني اتى في التقرير الحديث عن صاروخ
فقط اصاب فقط جناح الطائره هذا امر غير
ممكن يعني اي نوع من الصواريخ لديه راس
حربي وهذا الراس يعمل بعده اشكال يعني
هناك الفيوز او المفجر الذي يعمل ما يسمى
بالبروكسي متي يعني هذا الصاروخ عندما يصل
على مسافه معينه من الطائره يرسل ذبذبات
فتعود لتحدد المسافه وعليه يتم التفجير
وهذا امر سيفجر الطائره ككل لن يكون هناك
فقط الجناح وهناك الاصابه المباشره
الاصابه المباشره هي اصابه ستفجر الطائره
الى فتاه وبالتالي لن تنزل وتسقط وكانها
جسم واحد الاكثر ترجيحا وهذا اعود فاقول
البارحه تحدثنا عنه الاكثر ترجيحا هو ان
يكون عمل من الداخل وليس بالضروره ان يكون
عمل تفجيري قد يكون عمل تخريبي ميكانيكي
بمكان ما اوكي لانه العمل التخريبي بمكان
ما لن يترك هذه الاثار الكيميائيه التي ت
تي الى يعني قد يعني يتم الكشف عنها
جنائيا ب خلال مختبر لمعرفه ما بكون هذا
العمل التخريبي عاده يعني ما الذي يكون قد
اترب يعني
عمل يعني من من قام بهذا العمل هو خبير في
هذا الموضوع او من هناك قال له ان ان يكون
هذا العمل بهذا المكان وهذا العمل بمكان
ما هذا العمل بمكان ما قد يؤدي على مرت
ارتفع مستوى معين سرعه معينه الى خلل
بمكان ما يؤدي الى الخلل التقني ولكن
بالتاكيد ليس خللا بشريا اشكرك جزيل الشكر
من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي في ردود الفعل بشان تحطم
طائره بريغوجين قال رئيس هيئه الاركان
الامريكيه المشتركه مارك ميلي ان بلاده لا
علاقه لها على الاطلاق بتحطم طائرات
بريغوجين مضيفا ان مقتل بريغوجين
تكون له تداعيات في مناطق وجود فاجنر في
العالم كما قال المسؤول العسكري الامريكي
انه لم يفاجا بسقوط طائره قائد فاجنر وان
تمرد بريغوجين عرضه
للخطر قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه بات رايدر ان تقيييم بلاده
الاولي يشير الى ان بريغوجين قد قتل اضاف
رايدر في مؤتمر صحفي ان التقارير الصحفيه
بشان تعرض الطائره لصاروخ ارض جو غير
دقيقه تقييمنا الاولي يشير الى ان من
المحتمل ان بريغوجين قد قتل ونواصل تقييم
الوضع التقارير الصحفيه بشان تعرض الطائره
لصاروخ ارض جو غير دقيقه وفق تقييمنا ولا
شيء يشير الى حصول
ذلك من بوستن ينضم الينا جلين كارل الضابط
السابق في وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه
مرحبا بك سيد جلين
كارل باعتقادك ومن وجهه نظرك ما هو
السيناريو الذي يعد الاكثر ترجيحا لما حدث
لهذه الطائره التي قتل على متنها
برجوج انا كحالي غيري قد قلت عندما كانت
هنالك عندما توقفت محاوله انقلاب ان برجوج
عليه ان يتفادى الوقوف بقرب من النافذه او
بالقرب من سلم بالتالي ما حدث ليس بال
المفاجئ على الاطلاق تخميني هو ان بوتين
اراد او احس انه بحاجه الى ان ينتظر لفتره
من الوقت قبل ان يتخذ اي خطوه لكي لا تبدو
هذه الخطوه كحركه يائسه لكن بدلا من ذلك
مثلا لكن استهداف شخص مثير للمص لمشاكل
بدم بدم بارد من اجل ان يظهر سيطرته
الطريقه التي استخدمت اطلاق صاروخ على
طائره وكان هنالك قتل لعده اشخاص اخرين
تخميني ان بوتين تصرف بهذه الطريقه تعتقد
انه جرى اطلاق صاروخ على الطائره سيد جلان
كار
لقد رايت
عده تص مقاطع فيديو
تظهر ان هنالك جزءا مفقودا لا اعرف اذا ما
كان هذا الطائره التي كان فيها بريكو لكن
مقطع الفيديو الذي رايته والتقارير
والتحليلات التي سمعناها من المسؤولين
الامريكين
وخبراء الاستخبار المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
قالوا كان هنالك استخدام لكلمه نسي لا
اتذكرها الان لكن كان هنالك استهداف لهذه
الطائره عن طريق جسم ما هذا الامر يدفعني
الى الاعتقاد ان هذا ربما ما
حدث لربما علمت ان البنتاغون قال لانه
يستبعد هذه الفرضيه فرضيه صاروخ الارض جو
ان تكون قد اصابت
الطائره لماذا
باعتقادك اعلم بهذا الامر الجزيره دائما
هي سباقه في نقل الاخبار اولا باول لم
اعرف بهذا الامر وانا متاكد ان
البنتاجون
لا لا يقوم ب اعطاء معلومات خاطئه وانا
متاكد ان لديهم معلومات عن الصواريخ وعن
قاعدات قاعده اطلاق الصواريخ اذا اذا ما
قال البنتاجون ان هذا الحادث لم يحصل بهذه
الطريقه يقبل هذا الامر ربما قد تكون
الطائره قد انفجرت
و او حصل انفجار داخلها اعتقد ان ما
فاجاني هو ان اشخاص على الطائره معظمهم
كانوا هما كبار القاده والمساعدين لبريك
وجن في الوقت الذي كان فيه لسنوات وحسب
التقارير كانوا حذرين في ممارساتهم
الامنيه ولم يكونوا يسافرون في نفس
الطائره ولاسباب امنيه بالتاكيد بالتالي
اثار فضولي ان وجودهم مع برجوج في نفس
الطائره شكرا لك جلين كارل الضابط السابق
في وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه من
بوستن الى التطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا حيث قال المتحدث باسم
المخابرات الاوكرانيه اندريه يوسوف ان
عمليه الانزال الخاصه التي نفذتها
المخابرات الاوكرانيه بالتعاون مع القوات
البحريه في شبه جزيره القرم الليله
الماضيه اسفرت عن مقتل 30 جنديا روسيا
وتدمير اربعه زوارق
روسيه
[موسيقى]
اعلن البيت الابيض ان مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جيك سليفن عقد اجتماعا خماسيا مع
نظرائه من فرنسا والمانيا وايطاليا
والمملكه المتحده وقال البيت الابيض ان
مستشاري الامن القومي للدول الخمس شددوا
على اهميه عاده النيجر الى طريق النظام
الدستوري ودعم الدور القيادي لمجموعه
ايكواس اضاف ان مستشاري الامن القومي
اكدوا مواصله دعم بلدانهم لاوكرانيا
للتصدي للهجوم الروسي مهما استغرق الامر
ومساعدتها في اعاده
الاعمار جددت الجزائر موقفها الرافض لاي
تدخل عسكري في النيجر وتمسكها بالحوار
السياسي وحذر الامين ال لوزاره الخارجيه
الجزائريه لوناس مكرمان الذي اجرى محادثات
مع قاده الانقلاب في النيجر من انعكاسات
من انعكاسات اي تدخل عسكري على المنطقه
باسرها وقال المسؤول الجزائري ان بلاده
تواصل مساعيها لتحقيق الاستقرار في النيجر
لكنه لم يحدد ما اذا كانت بلاده تطرح
مبادره او
وسط اكد وزير خارجيه مالي وبورك نفاس
تضامن بلديهما مع النيجر وقال انهما يثمن
قرار رئيس المجلس العسكري في النيجر
بالموافقه على انتشار قوات من بلديهما في
النيجر لمساعدتها في صد ما وصف ما وصفاه
بالعدوان المحتمل الذي تخطط له مجموعه
ايكواس كما اتفق الوزيران الذان يتراس
وفدين من بلديهما خلال اجتماعات اجريت في
نيام عاصمه النيجر على تشكيل اطار للتعاون
وتنسيق المواقف في مختلف القطاعات لمواجهه
التحديات ودعوه الدول الراغبه في الالتحاق
بهم قال عبد السلام ابو بكر رئيس نيجيريا
السابق ورئيس وفد اكواس للتفاوض مع المجلس
العسكري في النيجر ان رئيس المجلس العسكري
عبد الرحمن تياني رفض طلب الوفد اعاده
الرئيس محمد بازوم الى منصبه اضاف رئيس
وفد ايكواس في تصريحات ان تياني قال ان
اطلاق سراح الرئيس بازوم ممكن اذا تم
التفاهم على ذلك لكنه لن يعود للسلطه كما
ان تياني اكد ان مده الفتره الانتقاليه هي
ثلاث سنوات وطالب بفتح الحدود المغلقه
واعاده الكهرباء الى
النيجر وكان رئيس ما يطلق يطلق على نفسه
المجلس الوطني لحمايه الوطن في النيجر عبد
الرحمن تياني التقى وفدا من علماء نيجيريا
وكان الوفد الذي يراسها الشيخ عبد الله
بالالو قد وصل الاربعاء الى نيامي واجتمع
مع التياني في ثاني زياره له منذ الاطاحه
بالرئيس محمد بازوم وكان المجلس قد رحب في
وقت سابق بواسطه وفد علماء نيجيريا لانهاء
الازمه السياسيه في
[موسيقى]
النيجر
من المتوقع ان يسلم الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب نفسه في وقت لاحق
اليوم الى سجن مقاطعه فولتن بولايه جورجيا
تنفيذا لطلب المدعيه العامه في المقاطعه
ضمن القضيه المتعلقه بنتائج انتخابات 2020
في الولايه وتظاهر عشرات من انصار ترامب
امام السجن للتنديد بما يعتبرونه تسييس
للقضاء ومؤسسات السلطه التنفيذيه لملاحقه
ترامب ومحاوله منعه من الترشح والفوز في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله معنا من امام سجن مقاطعه فولتن في
ولايه جورجيا مراسل الجزيره مراد هاشم
مراد نقترب معك اكثر من المشهد والاجواء
المرافقه لما سي حدث بعد قليل تسليم ترامب
نفسه للسلطات
هناك مرحبا السي بالفعل الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب غادر قبل قليل مطار نيوورك
في ولايه نيو جيرسي في طريقه الى هنا حيث
يتوقع ان يسلم نفسه في الساعه السابعه
والنصف بالتوقيت المحلي الى هذا السجن
الذي نقف امامه الان سجن مقاطعه فولتون اي
بعد قرابه ساعتين من الان بطبيعه الحال
كما نشاهد هناك اجراءات امن مشدده بانتظار
ترامب تتزامن مع مظاهرات لا تظهر في
الصوره ولكن نرى هنا مظاهرات متفرقه
لانصار ترامب وكذلك لعدد من معارضيه ممن
يطالبون ب سجنه
ومحاسبته بطبيعه الحال ترامب سيخضع في هذا
السجن الذي يوصف بانه السجن سيء السمعه
بالنظر الى
الظروف داخل هذا السجن هناك 17 متهما او
سجينا توفوا هذا العام والعام الماضي داخل
السجن بسبب هذه الظروف السيئه اضافه الى
ظروف وانتهاكات اخرى ادت الى استقالات فيه
سوف يمر بذات الاجراءات التي يمر بها اي
متهم عادي بما في ذلك اخذ الصور وبالتالي
سيكون ستكون هذه المره الاولى التي تؤخذ
فيها وتلتقط صوره لترامب
كسجين ولو مؤقتا داخل هذا السجن ومن
المرجح ان تنشر هذه الصوره كما تم مع بقيه
المتهمين وعددهم عش ممن سلموا انفسهم الى
ذات السجن وتم نشر صورهم ايضا ستؤخذ
بصماته بعد ذلك يغادر يتوقع ان يمضي ترامب
اقل فتره مقارنه ببقيه المتهمين اذ وصلت
هذه الفتره الى حدود الساعه فيما يتعلق
ببقيه المتهمين لكن كما هو معروف الظروف
الامنيه المحيطه بالرئيس السابق تدفع الى
هذه الاجراءات المشدده وسيغادر بعد ذلك
مباشره الى ولايه نيو جيرسي كان ترامب
تعاهد ووافق على دفع كفاله ماليه قدرها
200000 دولار من اجل الافراج المشروط
اضافه الى تعهد تتعلق بعدم تهديد الشهود
وبقيه المتهمين السي بانتظار ذلك طبعا
تبقى معنا مراد هاشم من مقاطعه فولتن في
ولايه جورجيا لنتابع معك كل المستجدات
المتعلقه بهذه القضيه الان معنا من واشنطن
الدكتور جون مالكم رئيس قسم الشؤون
القانونيه والقضائيه في مؤسسه رج فاونديشن
دكتور جون مالكم كيف تختلف هذه القضيه
التي يواجهها ترامب هذه المره عن باقي
القضايا
هي مشابهه نوعا ما الى التهم الاخيره التي
قدمها المدعي الحكومي جاك سميث بمعنى ان
هذين التهمتين هي تغطي محاولات الرئيس
ترامب من اجل عكس
او الفاظ على نتائج
الانتخابات لكن هنالك تهمتان
اخرت كان هنالك فيها سجلات اعمال زائفه
وايضا مساله
حيازه الاوراق السريه في فلوريدا اذا هذه
القضيه مختلفه في مساله ان الادعاء العام
فيلي ولس اختارت ان توجه التهم ليس فقط
الى ترامب لكن الى 18 شخصا اخرين كلهم
مرتبطين بحمله ترامب او مساله تقديم
الاستشاره لمحامي ترامب بالتالي هو توجيه
تهم بشكل اوسع بالتالي المحاكمه ستكون
اصعب في الشكل دكتور جون مالكم
سينتج عما يحدث بعد قليل عن تسليم ترامب
نفسه للسلطات في جورجيا سينتج عن ذلك صوره
جنائيه له وسيتعين عليه دفع كفاله من اجل
ان يخرج ما تاثير ذلك باعتقادك على صورته
في هذه
المرحله
هنالك مبلغ 200 الف دولار والسيده ترامب
رجل غني للغايه بالتالي هذا المبلغ لن
يشكل مشكله له هو لن يغادر البلد او يهرب
منه على ا حال بالتالي الادعاء العام
سيركز على ما اخذ هذا
صوره للرئيس اعتقد ان هذا امر بغايه السخف
لان الجميع يعرف كيف شكله لكن اعتقد ان
الديمقراطيين يظهرون هذا يستخدمون هذا
الامر ليظهروا انه يواجه مشكله جنائيه
كبيره اعتقد ان ايضا
الرئيس السابق ترامب سيضع هذه الصوره
ويقول ان وزاره العدل والدعاء العام كلهم
ضده ما يسمى ويزعم ان النظام قضائي فاسد
شكرا لك دكتور جون مالكم رئيس قسم الشؤون
القانونيه والقضائيه في مؤسسه ذا هريتج
فاونديشن ضيفنا من
واشنطن اعاد نقاش دول مجموعه بريكس
اقتراحا لانشاء عمله موحده بديله للدولار
الجدل حول الصعوبات التي ستواجه هذه
العمليه في ظل هيمنه الدولار كعمله
احتياطيه رئيسيه في العالم نتعرف على هذه
الصعوبات وعلى الطرق الممكن اعتمادها
لتحقيق عمله بديله في التقرير
التالي في سعي مجموعه بريكس لانشاء عمله
موحده قد تغنيها بالكامل عن استعمال
الدولار الامريكي يثار من جديد الحديث عن
معنى هذه الخطوه اقتصاديا وعن الطريق الذي
يجب ان تسلكه الدول الراغبه في الاستغناء
عن استخدام الدولار في التعاملات التجاريه
فالبلدان التي تنوي الهروب من ظل الدولار
غالبا ما تتبنى اساليب مختلفه لكنها قطع
في ضروره اعتماد البنوك المركزيه في هذه
الدول عمله احتياطيه بديله تسمح لها بدعم
نظامها المالي المحلي والمشاركه في
التجاره والمعاملات الدوليه ويمكن ان
تختار البنوك المركزيه الاحتفاظ باحتياطات
من الذهب او العملات الاخرى بدلا من
الدولار خاصه ان هذا الاخير غير مدعوم
بالذهب وقد فعلت الكثير من البلدان ذلك
حقا فوفقا لمجلس الذهب العالمي ارتفع طلب
البنوك المركزيه على الذهب في عام 2022
الى
1163 طنا متيا بزياده
15% على اساس سنوي ليصل الى اعلى مستوى
منذ عام
1950 وكطريقة
هي بالدولار لذا من الضروري ان تقوم الدول
الراغبه في الاستغناء عن الدولار باصلاحات
اقتصاديه عميقه لتفادي ارتفاع ديونها
الخارجيه من جهه اخرى يجب على هذه البلدان
ان تفكر في عمله جديده قادره فعلا على
تعويض الدولار وان تحل محله حتى تستطيع
كسب ثقه الاقتصاد العالمي كما ان تزايد
التكتلات الاقليميه والعابه قد يشكل مؤشرا
مساعدا على اهتزاز مكانه الدولار خاصه اذا
اقترحت هذه التكتلات تبني عمله موحده
تجمعها لكن عموما يبقى نجاح هذه الدول في
تعويض الدولار وسرعتها ايضا في تحقيق ذلك
معتمدين على حدوث تذبذبات في الاقتصاد
الامريكي من ثم فقدان الثقه بالدولار
الدولار الذي كتب قصه هيمنته بعد نهايه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه حين اجتمع الحلفاء
واعتمدوه باعتباره العمله الاحتياطيه
الرئيسيه في العالم حينها تم ربطه بالذه
الى عام
1971 اذ تم فصله بسبب عدم كفايه احتياطات
الذهب الامريكيه لكن الاستغناء عن الدولار
قد تترتب عليه عواقب محتمله فحسب الخبراء
ستبدا البنوك المركزيه بالتخلص من
احتياطاتها من الدولار وسوف يؤدي هذا الى
تضخم كبير والى ارتفاع اسعار الفائده
للتعويض عن فقدان القوه الشرائيه وانخفاض
اسعار الاصول لكن لا شيء مضمونا والتاريخ
اكبر دليل فقد كان صعود وسقوط
الامبراطوريات والعملات الاحتياطيه واضحا
على مر التاريخ من الامبراطوريه الهولنديه
مع الجلدر الى الامبراطوريه البريطانيه مع
الجنيه
[موسيقى]
الاسترليني في فقره المتابعه نعود الى قمه
بريكس الخمسه عش التي اختتمت اعمالها في
جوهانسبرج وتتزامن مع توتر عالمي على
خلفيه حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وتصاعد
التنافس الجيوسياسي في مناطق عده تضم
بريكس مجموعه متباينه من الدول تمتد من
الصين ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في العالم الى
جنوب افريقيا التي تواجه ازمه طاقه حاده
وروسيا التي تحرص على ان تظهر للغرب انها
ما يزال لديها اصدقاء والهند التي تعزز
تقاربها مع الغرب وكذا تفعل ز في عهد
زعيمها الجديد تمثل بلدان بريكس
23% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي العالمي و
42% من سكان العالم لكن المجموعه غير
متجانسه فدول الخمس الموزعه في اربع قارات
لديها اقتصادات ذات نمو غير متكافئ ما
الجديد اعلن قاده بريكس اليوم انه اعتبارا
من العام المقبل ستنضم دول جديده للمجموعه
هي السعوديه ومصر واثيوبيا والامارات
وايران والارجنتين ومع انضمام سته اعضاء
جدد يمثل التكتل الان
46% من سكان العالم وحصه اكبر من نتجه
الاقتصادي وكانت اكثر من 40 دوله قد عبرت
عن اهتمامها بالانضمام الى بريكس وطلبت 22
دوله الانضمام رسميا ويقول الخبراء ان ضم
دول من الجنوب في مجموعه العش الى بريكس
وامر منطقي في ظل سعي التكتل الى ان يبقى
ممثلا للاقتصادات
الناشئه الكبرى السؤال الذي يفرض نفسه هل
تقلق مجموعه بريكس واشنطن يرد مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي جيك سليفن بالقول
ان واشنطن لا ترى ان مجموعه بريكس بصدد
التحول الى منافس جيوسياسي للولايات
المتحده مشيرا الى علاقات قويه مع
البرازيل والهند وجنوب افريقيا و مواصله
اداره العلاقات مع الصين لكن ما الذي يجمع
اعضاء بريكس الحاليين قبل الانضمام الرسمي
للاعضاء الجدد يناير القادم تشترك بلدان
بريكس في المطالبه بتوازن اقتصادي وسياسي
عالمي متعدد الاقطاب وهذا هو العنوان
العريض ماذا في
التفاصيل بدات بريكس بطرح ما ك ما قد يكون
بدائل للنظام الدولي الذي تهيمن عليه دول
الشمال فرغم انها تضم اث 40% من سكان
العالم فان اعضائها الخمسه لديهم اقل من
15% من حقوق التصويت في البنك وصندوق
النقد الدوليين مقابل نحو
17% للولايات المتحده و 45% لمجموعه السبع
وتسعى دول المجموعه الى اقرار نظام دفع
وتحويلات ماليه جديد متعدد الاطراف
والجنسيات يشكل بديلا لنظام الدفع
الامريكي سويفت من جوهانسبرج ضم الينا
جوستافو دي
كافاليرو دي كارفاليو الباحث الاول في
معهد جنوب افريقيا للشؤون الدوليه والخبير
في تحليل السياسات للمنظمات الدوليه مرحبا
بك سيد جوستافو هذا التوسيع لمجموعه بريكس
الى اي مدى يسعف الهدف الذي تقول المجموعه
انها تسعى وراءه وهو خلق عالم متعدد
الاقضاب
نعم اعتقد ان كان قرارا مهما من ضمن
المجموعه وخاصه الطريقه التي تم فيها
تنويع الاقتصاديات في داخل المجموعه ليس
فقط في في ناحيه اساليب الاقتصاد
والصادرات والاستيراد لكن مساله التوازن
الجغرافي الذي رايناه في مساله التوسع
الان اعضاء جدد من جنوب من امريكا
الجنوبيه اثنان من افريقيا وثلاثه من
الشرق الاوسط وبهذا السياق فان من المهم
هذا امر مهم نحو الهدف الذي لدى الدول
فيما يتعلق ان تكون جزءا من هذه المنظومه
الدوليه والاقتصاد وهذا الامر سيسيطر على
نقاشات البريكس خلال السنوات القادمه
وخاصه عندما يتعلق الامر
بزياده خلق الفع مثلا والنقاشات التي ما
تزال في مراحلها المبكره فيما يتعلق
بالعملات الاحتياطيه ايضا على اي اساس
باعتقادك سيد جوستافو جرى قبول عضويه هذه
الدول دون غيرها من الدول الكثيره التي
تقدمت
العضويه اعتقد ان الدول الاعضاء اوضحت ان
هذه هي المرحله الاولى من التوسع للمجموعه
نعرف خلال الايام القليله الماضيه كانت
اجرت مناقشات جاده فيما يتعلق بدول مثل
البرازيل لم
تكن تسعى
لتوسع وايضا الاعضاء الاربعه الاخرى كانوا
مهتمين بهذا الامر
وبالتالي جعل من هذه الخطوه ممكنه
بالتاكيد كان هنالك عدد من الدول اشارت
انها مهتمه بالانضمام الى البريكس
بعض الهيكله وفيما يتعلق بالبرك بلس والذي
قد يرحب بعدد اوسع من الدول وخاصه عندما
قامت الدول بتقديم المعايير لاختيار
الاعضاء المستقبلين اعتقد ان هذا الامر
قدم ربما فكره اوضح للدول التي ترغب
الانضمام مستقبلا لكن من المهم ان نرى ما
هي النتائج المترتبه على هذا التوسع خلال
السنوات القادمه لان نجاح او فشل هذا
التوسع ربما سيشر للعديد او للدول الاخرى
اذا ما كانت ترغب بالاستمرار او انها
ستكون مهتمه بالانضمام الى البريكس ام لا
طيب الدول التي جرى قبول انضمامها الان
ماذا تستفيد باعتقادك من وراء الدخول في
هذا
النادي هنالك عده قضايا اعتقد احدها ان
البريكس اصبح منصه مهمه
خلال في العالم فيما يتعلق بتبادل الخبرات
والتعاون علينا ان نفهم انه في الوقت الذي
تحصل في القمه السنويه عل هنالك عده احداث
منذ بدايه العام والتي ستحصل بشكل دوري
وبرئاسة
الان في الاعتماد بشكل اكبر على الدولار
وخاصه عندما يقولون ان الدولار قد استخدم
لعده مرات كاداه سياسيه من اجل تحقيق
اهداف معينه بالتالي هنالك عده قضايا
نعتقد انها يمكن ان تكون مهمه للدول لكن
اعتقد الامر يعتمد بشكل كبير حول مساله
الدور او السياسي الذي ستلعبه الدول وما
هي الترتيبات التي سيتم وضعها خلال
السنوات القادمه وهل يتم سيكون هنالك ربما
ل الصوت العالمي الجنوبي في العالمي وايضا
الدور المتزايد في صندوق النقد الدولي
والبنك الدولي شكرا جزيلا لك من جوهانسبرج
جوستافو دي كارفاليو